it was the year 2000 and seven-year-old
zenya Chao was like a lot of children
her age bright but ignored she had a
youthful enthusiasm for knowledge and
learning and with the right
encouragement it was obvious she'd go on
to do great things but her parents were
both working two jobs apiece to make
ends meet so outside of school hours
little zenya spent a lot of her time
alone she learned to cook and clean for
herself since it would often be way past
her bedtime when her parents finally got
home from work they communicated largely
through sticky notes left for her on the
fridge before they left for work in the
morning it would be easy for someone
like zenya to fall through the cracks
her potential wasted and get forced into
the same endless Rat Race as her parents
and that probably would have happened if
her brush with
scp-1594 hadn't changed the course of
her life forever like a lot of parents
who couldn't spend as much time with
their children as they'd like Mr during
Mrs Chow gave zenya occasional gifts as
a way to try and make up for their
absence mostly they gave zenya new books
to add to a growing collection but their
two-bedroom apartment only had so much
space for books a year ago the family
had bought a new desktop computer to
share these days this would be the
answer to a lonely bookworm's prayers
but the internet was still in its
infancy back then everything changed
when her parents bought her a copy of
the Miss Jay's Wiz Kids Schoolhouse
CD-ROM Miss Jay's Wizkid Schoolhouse was
never a popular program produced by
shoot the moon's software in 1999 the
game sold poorly on the CD-ROM market
for five years until the company filed
for bankruptcy in 2004 but that didn't
matter to zenya as far as she was
concerned receiving a copy of Miss Jay's
Wiz kid Schoolhouse was nothing short of
a miracle and she was far more right
than she knew she didn't have just any
piece of primitive educational software
on her hands zenya Chao was playing with
magic after the software loaded a
cheerful figure appeared on zenya's
monitor this was Miss J A stylized 2D
teacher in a low res but colorful 3D
classroom what can you learn from Miss
Jay well pretty much anything and zenya
as a lonely kid without many friends had
all the time in the world she spent days
on end learning from Miss J and soon
zanya went from a bright child to a bona
fide child genius her largely absent
parents barely even noticed when their
child started demonstrating an advanced
knowledge of mechanical engineering and
a newfound fluency in Swahili and not
only did Miss Jay now known to zenya as
Miss Joyce teacher students with
Supernatural Effectiveness she also
seemed almost like she was alive
was a warm calm encouraging figure who
took a genuine personal enthusiasm in
the education and happiness of her
students more than many real teachers
even but sadly not all good things last
forever when zenya turned 12 her family
bought a new computer and the old Miss
Jay's Wiz Kids Schoolhouse CD-ROM was no
longer compatible with the new operating
system the disc gathered dust in the
closet while zenya passed through high
school and then got into a prestigious
college she received her PhD several
years earlier than expected and showed
such promise in her scientific field
that a certain organization took notice
you guessed it the SCP Foundation the
foundation is only interested in adding
the best and brightest to their ranks
and thanks to the tutoring from Miss Jay
zenya Chao certainly fit the bill she
was assigned to the role of Junior
researcher and little did she know she
was about to run into an old friend in
her new line of work the foundation
first discovered evidence of Miss Jay's
anomalous qualities while researching a
series of strange Forum posts in 2012.
on a thread discussing abandonware which
is software for which official support
is no longer available there were
multiple reports of a so-called living
character in an old CD ROM many of them
had owned as children seeing as the
technology to use the CD-ROM was
obsolete shoot the moons had reportedly
extremely low sales for the title and
nobody on the Forum had kept their copy
the foundation classified this apparent
anomaly as neutralized no problem that
was until then Junior researcher zenya
Chao was briefed on this particular SCP
10 years later she remembered exactly
what the Forum posters were talking
about and what's more she still had her
old copy at home the senior Foundation
researchers were astounded an
opportunity to study this forgotten
anomaly had just fallen into their laps
and it was all thanks to their brilliant
new Junior researcher zenya superiors
ordered her to bring in her copy of the
Miss Jay's Wizkid Schoolhouse CD-ROM and
then real testing began and after
rigorous examination of the software it
appears by all accounts that Miss J
really is the world's greatest teacher
in spite of the fact she's a collection
of pixels on a basic CD-ROM program from
the tail end of the 90s what Miss J
seemed to specialize in was intensive
courses she had the ability to make
students certifiable experts in almost
any subject through courses that can
last upwards of 30 hours and spread out
over just a few days but this isn't as
students become so enraptured in
learning that they forget accounting for
their most basic needs and experience a
decline in process story Miss Jay's
lesson plans account for regular
bathroom meal and even Recreation breaks
for students her talents easily account
for zenya chao's remarkable academic
success the same success that got her
picked up by the SCP Foundation
naturally if they had a technology on
their hands that could reliably create
experts and Geniuses with seemingly no
negative consequences the foundation
knew that Miss Jay and what she had to
teach could be immensely valuable in
their mission to effectively secure
contain and protect other anomalies but
we're not talking about the chaos
Insurgency here the foundation would
never start to use an anomaly for their
own benefit without proper testing so
that's exactly what they did their
experiments on scp-1594 began at site 15
and after ascertaining that Miss J pose
no real threat to her students they
recruited a local elementary school to
provide human test subjects closer to
miss Jay's intended demographic the
foundation found that there were a few
constraints between every lesson given
by Miss J to one of his students before
teaching the really mind-blowingly
complex stuff she would always begin
with a basic primer on letters colors
and numbers to make sure she and her
students were all on the same page
another constant was that all our
students would refer to her as some
variation of Miss J with examples
including the names Miss Julie Miss
Jenny and Miss Joy one experiment was
performed on Amy Myers a little girl
from the third grade her academic
records showed she was a bright and
eager student but she was described by
her teachers as being especially shy Amy
referred to miss Jay as Miss Janie and
asked to be given a lesson on her
favorite animal cats of course Miss Jay
gladly obliged and gave Amy a 15-hour
lesson split over the course of two days
which the foundation closely observed by
the time the lesson was completed the
results were truly astonishing Amy
demonstrated knowledge of feline
Behavior diet and Physiology on the
level of professional animal behavioral
scientists she became upset when the
session ended and the program was
switched off having become attached to
miss Jay no further anomalous effects
were reported the next subject was a
student from the second grade named
Devon Williams Devon had a poor academic
record and behavioral issues stemming
from several learning disabilities in
the past teachers had reported Devon
having real difficulty engaging with
their lessons and the foundation wanted
to see if Miss Jay's Supernatural
teaching abilities fared any better
Devon chose to be educated on the
subject of trains and was given a
15-hour course on the subject spread
over two days Devon had no difficulty
engaging with these lessons and after
their conclusion he displayed a level of
knowledge on Railway engineering
comparable to a graduate level education
on the subject Devon was so engaged in
his lessons that he had to be physically
removed from the room once the course
had completed because he'd become so
attached to his new teacher the
foundation was feeling extremely
optimistic about the prospect of using
Miss J to train potential recruits
seeming as she seemed to be able to
teach even the most difficult juvenile
subjects however the foundation needed
to prove that Miss J could be just as
effective teaching adults for the next
test they recruited
d-14417 a 24 year old member of d-class
personnel who described himself as a
poor student and tested poorly on
pre-screening attentiveness and focus
evaluations he was the perfect candidate
for the first adult test of Miss J to
the Delight of the foundation higher-ups
d-14417xl Miss J made him a verifiable
expert in law and he was able to pass a
mock bar exam with a grade of 310 after
his course much like the children he
felt intense sadness once the experiment
ended stating that Miss Jay was the best
teacher he had ever had he's since been
selectively anesthetized released and is
pursuing a degree in criminal law with
his new knowledge needless to say the
foundation was impressed the last thing
they needed to know was who exactly this
Miss J truly was to do this they'd
conduct an interview and thankfully they
already had someone who had a
pre-established rapport with the subject
zenya Chao when zenya began the
interview Miss Jay recognized her
immediately she was delighted to see one
of her students go on to find such
success in her chosen field zenya
questioned Miss Jay on what she truly
was and Miss Jay responded that she
honestly wasn't sure all she knew for
sure was that she was passionate about
helping lonely children who love to
learn Embrace their education that's
really all there was to it and it
appears she was telling the truth so far
the foundation has found nothing that
hints at a nefarious motivation behind
Miss Jay's action
it would appear she truly does just want
to help children zenya touched by the
kindness that this safe class anomaly
showed her as a neglected child and
having now seen the positive impact that
she had on children like her thanked
Miss J for all she'd done and left the
interview happy that there was an SCP
out there who just wanted to change
people's lives for the better and
probably all of us would be a little
better off if there were more after all
this was one of the few scps who changed
a few good people's lives for the better
and all of us can probably learn
something from the kindness and patience
of Miss Jay in June of 1985 Mark Johnson
and his wife of 10 years Sophie were on
vacation in Myrtle Beach having a great
time while they relaxed on the sand
Sophie decided to take a picture of her
husband for their scrapbook so she
pulled out the Polaroid Super Color 645
that she'd bought specifically for the
trip she pressed the button waiting for
the picture to print pulled it out and
shook it what she expected to see was a
shot of Mark lying on his beach towel
what she got was a picture of her
husband in the arms of his secretary
they say that a picture speaks a
thousand words but this particular
camera takes pictures that are worth
even more than that when developed the
pictures taken with this normal looking
Polaroid camera revealed the innermost
desires of the person being photographed
welcome to the story of
scp-978 the desire camera the main
reason the foundation keeps scp-978
Under Wraps is due to its use as an easy
form of blackmail all anyone with access
to the camera would have to do is snap a
few covert photos and they'd have
instant dirt on the world's most
powerful people to further stop this
camera from falling into the wrong hands
the containment guidelines strictly
forbid the use of the camera for
anything other than simple documentation
and all uses of it must be thoroughly
logged and checked so now that you know
what the camera does it's time to look
at what kinds of strange and mysterious
photos it's taken after all who doesn't
want a chance to gain insight into the
minds of the foundation's most famous
and dangerous inmates first to serve as
a control the team took a photo of a
blue office chair no change was recorded
proving that the camera didn't work on
non-anomalous inanimate objects some of
the earliest tests of the camera were
the photos that the research team took
of each other one by one the doctors and
their assistants were photographed in
neutral poses smiling as if for a
completely normal photo then they waited
while the photos developed like normal
Polaroids most of the research team had
minimal changes in their photos one was
shown slouched in his chair drinking
from a flask one was shown in her
civilian clothes getting ready to go
home from work one doctor was in the
exact same pose but with a different and
colored tie on the last assistant
photographed however had their picture
come out wildly different than how they
were posed their desire revealed by the
camera was so shocking that it had to be
redacted and the assistant was placed on
temporary psychiatric leave following
this first successful test the doctor in
charge of the project ordered a second
round of tests to be conducted this time
on a series of d-class personnel a
picture of 1D class who was photographed
while eating in the cafeteria showed up
as scuba diving on vacation with his
wife and child he was allowed to keep
the picture afterwards another had a
similar result he was photographed in a
neutral pose like the members of the
research team had been and when the
picture developed the d-class was seen
holding a smiling baby whom he
identified as his one-year-old daughter
after that the results of the scp-978
test started to get a little well weird
a notoriously Twisted d-class known as
7294 was photographed in his cell and
when the Polaroid developed he was in
the same cell playing a cello made out
of a dismembered mannequin
d217-017 was a late stage victim of
scp-217 a virus that turns organic
matter into metal you would assume that
her innermost desire would be to be
cured of her disease but when she was
photographed in her cell the resulting
Polaroid showed her completely made of
metal kneeling and praying at the base
of a black Obelisk one d-class who had
been rendered comatose and was on life
support was photographed in their
hospital room their picture showed them
as only a limp deflated skin in their
photo the photograph of another d-class
who had become increasingly listless and
apathetic since their integration into
the d-class program resulted in a
picture that was exactly the same as
they appeared in reality except the
light in their cell was slightly dimmer
intrigued by these results the research
team wanted to see how the camera would
react to scp-1 38 a type of metal that
blocks the psychic properties of other
scps a helmet was made from the material
and placed on a d-class who was given an
adult magazine to read while his photo
was taken when the photo was developed
it was extremely blurry upon close
analysis the figure of the d-class
reading the magazine could still be made
out and around him the faint images of
several nude people could be seen the
research team wanted to see if the
results were the same when the camera
was used on animals photos of the lab
mice and rabbits showed them eating or
mating in their respective Polaroids a
zebra finch was shown escaping its cage
while a guard dog and its Handler were
shown playing fetch in the park when
cockroaches were photographed there was
no difference visible between the
picture and reality but the most
exciting test results came when the
camera was tested on other scps for a
few of the scps tested there was no
visible difference between the picture
and reality this was the case for
scp-170 3 the sculpture
scp-343 nickname God
scp-014 an immortal man who is over time
being turned into concrete and
scp-063 the world's best toothbrush when
scp-035 better known as the possessive
mask was photographed in its glass case
the picture showed an unidentified
individual wearing the mask sitting on a
throne and surrounded by three masked
corpses the team took a picture of
scp-043 a haunted copy of The White
Album that was being interrogated while
on a turntable in the picture the album
was being returned to its sleeve they
then photographed scp-049 the plague
doctor standing in his cell in the
picture the plague doctor is hugging an
unidentified small child and surrounded
by instances of
scp-049-2 when they took a picture of
scp-050 a mischievous statue of a monkey
reading a book the result was
predictably playful given that scp's
history of pulling pranks the photo that
came out of the camera showed the camera
itself with another picture of itself
coming out of the developing slot
microscopic analysis revealed that this
recursive photography kept going until
the cameras in the pictures of the other
cameras were too small to see the team
next photographed scp-053 the young girl
and the photo was taken as the young
girl was drawing with crayons in her
cell in the picture she was riding
through a sunny field on the back of her
friend
scp-682
scp-053 and scp-682 were even wearing
matching bows dresses and pink nail
polish when they took a picture of
scp-096 the shy guy though the picture
showed
scp-096's cell with nothing in it
scp-085 the living 2D sketch known as
Cassie was photographed tinkering with a
drawn car in the developed photo Cassie
was engaged in the same activity but
both she and the car were now
three-dimensional the team took a photo
of scp-106 the old man emerging from a
wall within his cell when the photo
developed it showed the old man roaming
a wheat field near an old farmhouse from
the porch of The Farmhouse an older
woman is greeting as cp106 with open
arms they also took a photo of scp-168 a
sentient calculator sitting on a table
in its containment cell in the picture a
teenage boy is seen doing complex math
homework using the calculator next to
him on the table are thick textbooks
with titles like complicated math
difficult math and math you need your
calculator for the photo of scp-261 a
vending machine that dispenses snack
products from alternate universes showed
the SCP in its usual hallway almost
completely buried in coins
scp-507 an otherwise normal man who
unwillingly teleports between Dimensions
was photographed while eating in the
cafeteria the developed picture showed
him dressed as a foundation researcher
talking to other researchers when
scp-682 was photographed floating in its
containment tank the resulting picture
showed the SCP surrounded by the corpses
of all of the foundation staff and
mauling the person who had taken the
photo her researchers note accompanying
this photo reads well that was
predictable yes yes it was just for the
fun of it the team also tested the
camera's effects on a few other
Foundation Personnel they took a photo
of Dr bright while he was arguing with
Dr klaff the picture that came out
showed a tombstone engraved with the
words Jack Bright resting at last the
team also took a photo of Dr clef as he
stormed out in a hop following the
argument given that klaf's face cannot
be photographed they were curious as to
what the results would be the picture
showed little difference compared to
reality save for the fact that cleft's
head was replaced by an image of a hand
making a rude gesture upon closer
examination of the photo the team also
realized that there was a young girl in
the background who strangely had cloven
Hooves instead of feet a young scp-166
perhaps the team then took a photo of Dr
Fisher holding his pet hamster contrary
to expectations the picture revealed not
Dr Fisher's desires but the hamsters
showing the hamster sleeping peacefully
in its cage with Dr Fisher nowhere to be
seen as you can see from these test logs
the effects of the camera are well
inconsistent with some photos showing
very immediate simple whims and others
showing the subject's deepest and most
secret desires while the researchers
working with scp-978 seem like they had
a lot of fun getting to peek into the
minds of all their co-workers and test
subjects there's no telling what kind of
pandemonium could be Unleashed if
someone on the outside ever got a chance
to use it thank thankfully the camera
which has been classified as safe for
obvious reasons is kept securely in
security Locker hj-12 at site 17 which
means none of us have to worry about our
own pictures taken by the desired camera
leaking out but if someone did get the
camera out and took your picture what do
you think they'd see the SCP Foundation
has encountered and contained some of
the most fearsome entities in human
history and even some from long before
us shaved Apes were ever walking across
the Earth they've gotten their hands on
ancient gods humanoid creatures with
deadly powers and more than one item
with the capacity to bring about the end
of the world as we know it but not
everything at the SCP Foundation can
kill you or would even want to sometimes
an SCP Has No Agenda other than going
about their lives making friends or even
helping people instead of wanting to eat
you for dinner these entities would
rather sit down for a meal and a chat
with you no apocalyptic ambitions hear
just Good Vibes today we're taking a
look at some of the friendliest scps of
all time first off is an SCP that's just
as sweet as it is sad if you ever
encounter
scp-49999 you probably don't have long
left to live that's not because it's
going to kill you or even hurt you but
because 49.99 visits people who are
already at death's store manifesting as
a humanoid figure dressed in dark
clothing
scp-4999 appears to a person about 20
minutes before their death as long as
the subject is awake and alone it will
then sit down near their bed and offer
them a cigarette it will then light one
for itself and as it smokes hold the
dying person's hand or place a
comforting hand on their shoulder it
will stay there with them providing a
silent sense of peace until they have
slipped away may not be friendly in the
most traditional sense but scp-4999
displays a great deal of kindness and
compassion in making sure that no one
ever dies alone though some of the
friendliest scps are serious others are
quite silly this is the case for
scp-2991 The Entity is a striped
multi-colored scarf capable of changing
lengths the scarf appears to be sentient
and behaves in a docile manner
communicating by forming itself into the
shape of letters and spelling out words
the scarf enjoys attention and becomes
bored if left in its containment box for
too long and as expressed a desire to
play when asked if it was made to be fun
the scarf responded Yes and then wrapped
itself around the interviewer's hand and
then went to sleep it does not seem to
have any interests other than playing
and spending time wrapped around people
keeping them warm and cozy it's
basically just an ordinary scarf except
it's able to move on its own and desires
the company of humans sounds pretty darn
friendly to us some scps are perfectly
nice friendly people people who have no
control over their own anomalous
properties and would probably prefer
just to live out a mundane existence
free from any unusual activity
unfortunately you don't always get what
you want and neither does scp-507 507 is
for all intents and purposes and
ordinary human man with one notable
exception against his will he routinely
finds himself teleported into alternate
Dimensions appearing in them and
returning to his original one seemingly
at random aside from these odd stressful
occurrences 507 is a jovial individual
who enjoys meeting other scps and
chatting with researchers at the
foundation about the Paranormal aside
from his Dimension hopping he is no
different from any Pleasant stranger you
might encounter on the street while some
entities like 507 behave like a neighbor
to the SCP Foundation others like
scp-131 are more like house pets scp-131
refers to a pair of creatures nicknamed
the the iPods two teardrop shaped
creatures about one foot high one orange
and one yellow with a single blue eye in
the middle of each of their bodies their
intelligence has been compared to common
house cats and they are very curious
loving to roll around the facility and
see what everyone is getting up to they
appreciate attention and affection and
seek more of it from those who they bond
to following them around like a lost
puppy they may look strange at first but
their behavior is downright adorable and
as you may know from some of our other
videos when certain deadly anomalies
like SCP-173 Escape they can storm in
and save lives so they're not only
adorable they're adorable Heroes
sometimes an SCP with the best of
intentions can cause harm to Foundation
Personnel without meaning to this was
the case for
scp-2337 a male Corn Creek bird capable
vocalizations loud enough to cause
permanent hearing damage though he
possesses is this ability he has never
used it to cause deliberate harm while
in Foundation custody instead he simply
wants to chat with the Personnel
speaking in a language similar to
English the bird which responds to the
name Dr Spanko is very cooperative and
always excited to speak with research
staff especially delighted when called
by his name he may be a bit loud from
time to time but who isn't he's not
malicious just enthusiastic sometimes an
scp's good intentions are not
misinterpreted or inadvertently harmful
but simply as helpful as they were meant
to be enter
scp-662 a small silver handbell that
when shaken summons a short well-dressed
classic British butler named Mr Deeds Mr
Deeds will address the ringer of the
Bell by their name and title and perform
tasks for them he is extremely polite
and even when given a task that he does
not wish to or is unable to complete he
declines with the utmost respect his
style of friendliness may be more formal
but he's good company just the same and
we've heard he mixes a mean or in this
instance a nice drink too many of the
nicest scps to be around are similar to
pets but very few were deliberately
intended to live in one's home as a
companion scp-111 is an exception 111
refers to a species of invertebrates
resembling snails also referred to as
Dragon snails unlike ordinary snails
these creatures are warm-blooded highly
intelligent and capable of breathing
fire though they should be handled with
care hatchlings are capable of
imprinting on their owners much like
other baby animals and likely would make
a lovely pet for a fireproofed household
Unfortunately they are all in Foundation
custody so there is no way to find out
for yourself some of the previous scps
in this video are similar to ordinary
pets but scp-529 actually is an ordinary
pet with one small anomalous change
scp-529 or Josie is a small house cat
with gray Tabby markings and only half
of a body don't get upset she is not
injured or in any pain for some reason
the rear end of her body from tail to
the bottom of her rib cage is simply not
there the place where the cat's body
ends appears as pure black to the naked
eye and absorbs light the area does not
appear to be invisible but it is simply
not there in spite of this Josie
experiences no adverse effects moving
around as if the back half of her body
were still there there are no
containment procedures in place for
Josie and she is allowed to freely roam
the facility purring rubbing up against
personnel's legs for attention playing
with balls of string and little mouse
toys and begging for pieces of cheese as
a treat creatures like Josie the half
cat provide a morale boost to those that
encounter them but entities like
scp-5094 can provide material benefits
to the lives of those they they meet and
help them to make a change for the
better
scp-1594 or Miss J is the main character
of a children's educational CD-ROM game
called Miss Jay's Wizkid Schoolhouse
Miss Jay who is unable to leave the
computer program has only one interest
educating others she can teach a given
student about essentially any subject
including particle physics and Cubist
sculpture she conducts her lessons over
the course of several days up to 30
hours in length with breaks for meals
and trips to the bathroom sprinkled
throughout test subjects who studied
with Miss J have described her as the
best teacher they have ever had and she
helped to d-class leave the foundation
and begin a career studying criminal
justice she even recognized a former
student now a junior researcher at the
foundation and expressed a light at
seeing how far he had come since her
first lesson with them many of the
friendlier scps have a great deal of
knowledge they are eager to share and
one of the most eager out there is
scp-186 67 or Lord Theodore Thomas
Blackwood Lord Blackwood identifies
himself as a British Explorer and
naturalist as well as a war veteran
which is a bit perplexing considering he
is also a neon sea slug measuring only
4.6 inches in length in spite of this he
enjoys telling anyone who will listen
the tales of his past Expeditions which
he has been able to provide ample proof
of Lord Blackwood is happy to provide
entertainment and engaging Tales of
Adventure to anyone who would like to
take a listen to the stories of a sea
slug if you're interested in the company
of Lord Blackwood because of a fondness
for stories then you'll also want to
hear about scp-1230 1230 is a simple
unlabeled green hardcover book with
nothing strange about it at first glance
when it is opened the phrase a hero is
born can be seen on the first page the
reader looks at and the rest of the
pages will appear to be blank the true
anomalous effects of the book do not
kick in until the reader goes to sleep
there they will find themselves in a a
Fantastical world as the protagonist of
their own adventure story The Dream
World feels real as real as the waking
world and the story is tailored to the
interests of the reader in the dreams a
bearded man in a green cloak appears
known as the bookkeeper and acting as
the voice of scp-1230 he is helpful and
kind providing guidance to the dreamers
and attempting to ensure that they have
a wonderful time in their dream just
before the dreamer wakes up the man bids
them a sorrowful farewell and asks that
they please visit again soon it seems
that the book and its keeper want
nothing more than to give readers an
incredible experience and the chance to
live out their wildest dreams as the
hero of Their Own Story speaking of
objects that help people fulfill their
dreams
scp-2203 devotes itself to fulfilling
Romantic Dreams in the waking World 2203
is a standard Love Tester machine which
upon use dispenses a card with a name
and address of a person as well as a bit
of advice of how to approach them this
person is intended to be the soulmate of
the subject and when the subject
approaches their chosen person they find
that there is an immediate spark test
subjects who sought out their assigned
person have found either a spouse a
lover or a lifelong best friend it
refuses to suggest matches to
individuals with a history of domestic
violence indicating that its intention
is to only make matches that will be
happy healthy and safe many of these
friendly scps display a strong desire to
help others however they can few show
this desire more strongly than
scp-2295 2295 is a patchwork stuffed
teddy bear made from synthetic fiber and
cotton when it is near a human who has
experienced major trauma to an organ the
bear becomes active it will produce
scissors white thread and sewing needles
or a crochet hook and create a stuffed
version of the ailing organ the damaged
organ will somehow be replaced with this
New Creation it sounds as if this is the
start of a horrifying story but it isn't
the stuffed organ will function
perfectly defying all known laws of
medicine and science the bear wants to
help so badly that if there are no
useful materials nearby it will use
stuffing and fabric from its own body to
construct these organs when the bear is
unable to help a subject it will do
whatever it can to cheer them up and
make them happy and has even been known
to hold the subject and cry if there is
nothing else it can do above all the
bear simply wants to help heal the hurt
and the sick without a doubt though the
friendliest SCP that the foundation has
ever encountered is scp-999 also known
as the Tickle Monster 999 is a large
mass of orange slime that wants nothing
more than to play socialize and make
people happy Its Behavior has been
compared to that of a dog enjoying the
company of humans and other creatures
just touching its slimy surface is
enough to boost a person's mood and the
creature expresses special interest in
people who are unhappy or suffering from
emotional pain it refuses to eat meat
and goes out of its way to prevent any
harm to those around it even taking a
bullet for a person to save their life
999 is such a delight to be around that
it even managed to make the omnicidal
Rage of scp-682 subside if only for a
moment dogs might be considered man's
best friend but scp-999 is giving them
some Fierce competition for the role
though it would probably want to be best
friends with a dog too and hey if you
want your own scp-9999 to cuddle make
sure to check out scpswag.com to pick up
a tickle Monster Plush it's the next
best thing to having your very own
scp-999 to cuddle whenever you need a
little pick-me-up think back to your
childhood and ask yourself what was the
most pain you've ever felt while growing
up as we develop our understanding of
pain evolves according to our different
EXP experiences the older we get the
injuries we suffered as children like a
scraped knee or a bee sting rarely cause
us the same level of distress as they
used to of course when you are young and
unfamiliar with sensations of pain what
you really need in that moment straight
after you've fallen off your bike or
tripped playing soccer is someone to
pick you back up and give your sore spot
a kiss perhaps you even need a bowl of
warm soup to comfort you luckily for you
scp-348 is exactly that while many of
the anomalies held in containment by the
SCP Foundation have earned the Euclid or
inFAMOUS ketter class designations
scp-348 is one of the few considered to
be safe both in the sense it poses no
containment risk and in that it wouldn't
hurt a fly it is neither an ancient
Eldritch Abomination From Another
Dimension spreading its influence in our
world through memetic stimuli nor is it
a recording of a basketball game in
which all the players and Spectators are
trapped inside side it isn't an
indestructible limb generating reptile
or a towering winged being wielding a
flaming sword and guarding the entrance
to the Garden of Eden to put it simply
scp-348 is a bowl a white ceramic Bowl
the kind you would find almost anywhere
in the world it may even look
indistinguishable from the one in your
kitchen cabinet of course scp-348 is
hardly as ordinary as it outwardly
appears to be and it certainly isn't the
only inanimate object that the
foundation keeps safely stored away the
key thing that differentiates scp-348
from most other anomalies is how
genuinely harmless it is its anomalous
properties do not cause injury to any
individual that interacts with it nor
does this bowl have any adverse effects
on the world around it
scp-348 cannot bend or reshape reality
it does not cause the person eating from
it to have premonitions of their own
death and using it certainly does not
manifest a contract making entity at the
opposite side of the table so what makes
this bowl in any way anomalous what
about it categorizes it as an SCP and
not just a harmless piece of fine
Crockery well why don't we start with
how scp-348 was first discovered some
time ago the SCP Foundation was made
aware of rumors surrounding the child
living in an unknown part of the world
according to the intelligence gathered
by the foundation this child seemed to
possess some sort of healing ability or
at least this is what rumors suggested
upon further investigation the source of
these so-called remarkable recovery
abilities wasn't the child but appeared
to come from a small ceramic pole which
we now know as scp-348 this is not to
say that the bull has any inherently
Supernatural healing properties and it
doesn't impart any regenerative power to
those that eat from it either it does
heal in a certain sense but not in the
way you're probably imagining when the
SCP Foundation recovered scp-348 there
were no markings on it indicating where
the bowl came from or who it was
manufactured by the only visually
distinct details worthy of note were
flowery patterns that appeared to be
hand-painted around both the inside and
outside of scp-348 the ceramic surface
also bore the Chinese letters shangshini
which translates to the phrase thinking
of you the child that first discovered
it found the ceramic Bowl in the Attic
of their home the child's parents were
both full-time workers and seemed to be
somewhat neglectful of their child
although they refused to comment on this
but according to the findings of the SCP
Foundation the child had come to rely on
scp-348 deciding to further investigate
the anomalous properties of scp-348 the
foundation began testing it given that
the child who first discovered the bowl
had relied upon it tests involve
Foundation researchers presenting
certain children to scp-348 and
observing the results so was this bowl
haunted perhaps harboring some malicious
Spirit or entity that sought to corrupt
these children maybe even healing them
in order to somehow use them as a vessel
to break into our world no and while may
have not healed in any overt or expected
way it did heal in at least a
metaphorical sense if presented with an
injured child supporting any form of
minor ailments such as a cut or a runny
nose
scp-348 fills with warm soup and yes
that's right we said soup what kind you
may ask well that seems to vary
sometimes it is tomato soup other times
it might be chicken noodle soup while
the ingredients used in the soups are
often different there are notable
consistencies to lscp 348 heals if
anyone between the ages of 4 years old
and 18 years old sits down in front of
the blue flowered Bowl then scp-348 will
fill with soup numerous young test
subjects brought in by the foundation to
eat from this particular bowl of soup
have reported that they enjoyed their
meal usually finish finishing the entire
Bowl when permitted to by research staff
many of the injured children that were
tested have stated that the soup they
eat from scp-348 reminds them of their
parents cooking these children have
expressed contentment and feelings of
comfort after acquiring their various
cuts and bruises some even claim that
even though they were in a room all
alone they didn't feel lonely when they
were eating the soup and all the
anomalous properties don't end after a
child finishes the soup usually although
not always the bowl will leave the child
a message often some brief words of
reassurance or Comfort these messages
materialize on the inside rim of the
bowl and seem to be specifically
tailored to the subject that is just
eaten the words will not only be written
in the child's first language but are
often linked to the child's home life or
relationship with their parents messages
that appear on scp-348 usually fade over
time normally disappearing after a few
hours or when the bull refills with more
soup one test of scp-348 saw a little
girl age 8 and suffering from a sore
throat brought before the bowl according
to a background screening made by
research Personnel the girl lived with
her biological parents and apparently
had a good relationship with both her
mother and her father when scp-348
filled with super her the girl took
almost half an hour to finish eating and
afterwards reported that she felt her
sore throat get better as she ached by
the end of the meal this test subject
remarked that she felt completely normal
in this instance no message appeared
within the bowl another child was
brought in to continue the testing of
scp-348 this time a boy of 10. unlike
the previous test this boy was not on
good terms with his parents and often
argued with them at the time of testing
the boy had sustained several minor
bruises the result of a small accident
that occurred while the boy had been out
riding his bike much like the little
girl this subject ate the soup that
scp-348 presented him with this time
though the bull offered a message to the
boy the lettering found on the ceramic
surface of scp-348 Simply Red don't
forget to brush messages also appeared
when an 11 year old boy with a slight
cold ate soup from the bowl this child
had been adopted by a foster family and
after eating from scp-348 he saw the
message I'm glad you're happy appear
another young test subject a boy age six
had a similar experience in this
instance the child had several scrapes
and scratches from playing with his
friends his parents had divorced and he
was living with his mother at the time
of testing this time
scp-348's message to this boy read I'm
sorry son a seven-year-old girl
suffering from a cough was brought in
before
scp-348 she had lost her father to a
traffic accident sometime before testing
commenced and received the message I
love you after finishing her soup
further testing conducted by the
foundation revealed that anyone over the
age of 18 years who attempted to eat
soup from scp-348 experienced things
slightly differently unlike the children
older subjects mostly displayed a
disinterest in finishing their meal a
common complaint among those over 18 was
that the soup was missing something
however in a few isolated cases testing
scp-348 on older candidates still
revealed messages although the words
seemed to be fated not the clear
hand-painted blue that appeared when the
children had finished their soup one
woman aged 30 who was suffering from a
headache sat down in front of scp-348
much like it had done before the bowl
filled with soup and the woman ate as
with some of the younger subjects a key
aspect of This Woman's background seemed
to be what triggered the message to
appear specifically she admitted to
being on bad terms with her mother and
father the woman explained that she had
opted to live on her own isolating
herself from her family in fact she even
described having rejected an offer her
father made to her many years earlier
refusing some Career Training that he
was willing to give in order to help her
secure a job when she finished the soup
one word appeared in the bowl why
another woman who was 40 years old was
also brought in for the scp-348 testing
much like the previous subject she had
moved away from home and became
estranged from her parents over the
years but unlike the previous test this
woman had taken it upon herself to not
only send money to her parents but also
arranged senior care for both as well
prior to testing her father had died
peacefully of natural causes after
spending his last days in the care that
this woman had paid for as the woman ate
the soup from the bowl she remarked
about its apparently bitter taste but
also described her meal as fulfilling
after she had finished the words thank
you appeared with an scp-348 one other
adult subject that produced a noticeable
result from scp-348 was a 4 30 year old
male the results of this test appeared
to be the most distinctly different from
any previous adult or Child by now
researchers working for the SCP
Foundation had determined that familial
history seemed to play an important role
in the outcome of any interaction with
scp-348 and this individual was
certainly different to most the man in
question had murdered his father roughly
a year before the testing took place he
began the test with scp-348 while
Afflicted with aches in his back after
one Taste of the soup that appeared in
the Bowl before him the murderer was
immediately repulsed he complained about
the taste refusing to eat any more from
scp-348 shortly after the man began to
experience severe stomach pain the
potentially poisonous soup was disposed
of but scp-348 immediately filled with
salt water which took three hours to
disappear from the bowl despite
conducting numerous tests with subjects
of all ages and ailments the SCP
Foundation researchers have so far been
unable to determine the origins of the
messages that sometimes appear in
scp-348 some are theorized because of
the family histories of some children
and adults tested that the words somehow
come from the father of whoever eats the
soup since even when a subject's father
is alive or present in their life the
message seems to convey feelings that
their father has or would have other
researchers claim that this is just the
purpose of scp-348 to provide Comfort to
small children dealing with pain both
inside and out after all isn't providing
Comfort what a good bowl of soup
anomalous or not is best at a veteran
worker of the SCP Foundation sits at his
terminal performing one of the most
critical tasks in the entire
organization creating a file for an as
yet undescribed SCP but there's
something terribly wrong his eyes are
glazed over his mouth hangs up
is this a zombie or a trained Foundation
researcher
what is going on like any large
International Organization it takes more
than just the exciting action-filled
jobs to keep the wheels turning at the
SCP Foundation sure the head researchers
guards mobile task force soldiers and
members of the o5 command get all the
praise but a legion of number crunchers
cleaners and paper pushers are equally
important one such person was archivist
Walter Bainbridge who had been tasked
with digitizing some of the older
records that the foundation had on file
it was when he was innocently recording
the details on
scp-050-3060 that he first came under
the strange and startling effects of
scp-055 but the most peculiar part as
with all incidents of
scp-055's anomalous effects taking hold
is that Walter had no idea any of it was
happening in this new digitized filing
system he first took note of scp-053
Euclid class also known as the young
girl this anomaly was a seemingly normal
human female child who provoked
homicidal Insanity in those directly
exposed to her then scp-054 safe class
a non-aggressive humanoid female made
entirely of as well as biologically and
chemically identical to regular Spring
Water next
scp-056 Euclid Class A being that
changes form to suit its environment but
only when all observers lose focus of it
and then
scp-057 safe class an underground
chamber that crushes the humans who walk
Within it was at this point that Walter
received a concerned message from one of
his superiors at site 19 Mr Kovach the
message praised the thorough
digitization of the other anomaly's
records but was confused about why
Walter had left out any mention of
scp-055 immediately Walter was
embarrassed how could he have forgotten
scp-055 that iconic anomaly known for
well he couldn't quite say off the top
of his head but he'd be sure to look
into it a quick trip to the site-19
archive showed him that there was
actually quite a hefty file on the
nature of
scp-055 which must have been the result
of a huge number of studies what struck
him as strange was that all the files
were filled out in pen rather than being
typed up like a traditional file the
majority of these nodes were written in
shorthand too as though they were
frantically taken during the tests
themselves on extremely short notice
there weren't even any redactions Walter
made a mental note of what he had seen
put the file back in its proper place
and headed back to his computer terminal
however after riding in an almost
trance-like stay he looked back on his
work to see that he had written an entry
on
scp-058 a giant evil bovine heart with
insect legs and a scorpion Stinger
strange he thought that's when Walter
got a call from Mr Kovach on his
foundation issue phone and he didn't
sound happy he'd given Walter direct
instructions to go back and digitize the
files on zero five five and instead he'd
been working on zero five a what was the
meaning of This Walter was typically an
extremely loyal and diligent employee
but the verbal barrage from his
supervisor had him considering talking
back just this once and hoping it didn't
get him demoted to d-class and thrown
into 682's Acid Bath for playtime Walter
Galt picked up some courage and
interrupted Mr kovach's rant to ask if
he had any idea what scp-055 actually
was the line went silent for a moment
then his supervisor spoke again this
time with less confidence of course I
can tell you about
scp-055 it's a classic one of the first
hundred how could you forget it's uh or
yeah you know it's I think it's the one
with um
another long pause as Mr Kovach seemed
to search for the words but instead just
trailed off into silence knowing that
some of the anomalies on file were
dangerous mimetic hazards Walter was
worried for a moment that he may have
accidentally killed his boss by getting
him to think too hard about
scp-055 he asked if Mr Kovach was okay
and finally got a reply
I'm sorry I seem to have zoned out for a
second there what were we talking about
again but this time it was Walter who
couldn't answer he had no idea at all
what the two of them were discussing
just moments ago he felt disoriented and
kind of sick like they'd taken some low
level amnestics Mr Kovach told Walter to
get back to his filing duties and they'd
speak later Walter then checked the
messages he'd received from Mr Kovach
earlier and there it was plain as day
you missed zero five five go back and
digitize that before proceeding Mr K but
Walter had never even heard of an
scp-055 if such an anomaly even existed
what was going on here in that moment
Walter realized he was dealing with
something much Stranger Than Just a
standard digitization job after all how
could he properly complete his duties of
scp-055 seemed to be impossible to speak
right or even think about unless you
were directly observing it at that
moment Walter had to know and ask around
the entirety of site 19 to find the
answers if he had to
sadly for Walter he was about to embark
on a much more challenging task than he
could have ever imagined to paraphrase a
supposed quote from Socrates all I know
is that I know nothing and that's also
about the extent of the knowledge we
have on
scp-055 also known as the anti-mean and
the self-keeping secret what does it
look like when and how was it obtained
by the foundation what are its anomalous
abilities the this thing dangerous we
may never know because the only
anomalous ability of scp-055 that we're
aware of is the fact that nobody is
capable of retaining any information
about it it's crucial to note that
whatever zero five five is it isn't
invisible or Indescribable Foundation
Personnel are perfectly capable of
entering its containment chamber and
observing it without incident but mere
minutes after leaving the chamber any
memories of the particulars of 055 seem
to spontaneously erase themselves
hence the self-keeping secret but this
didn't deter Walter perhaps his greatest
Advantage was that he didn't know enough
about the thing he was investigating to
know how futile his mission was he
wanted to know the unknowable and a
pesky issue like impossibility wouldn't
stop him he'd get to whoever he needed
to at site 19 to get the answers he
needed of course most people had no
knowledge of the mysterious anomaly the
common response he got back from his
colleagues was zero five five do we even
have a zero five five well the
realization of sudden memory loss or the
realization of 055's existence has been
known to cause momentary stress there
are no known long-term physical or
mental effects from zero five five's
anomalous abilities it's a fleeting idea
in its purest form like forgetting why
you walked into a room 055 could be the
most harmless object on the foundation's
roster or the most deadly either way we
just don't know at times Walter worried
he was going insane zero five five and
everything related to it was gaslighting
him with zero five five even real the
one thing that proved to him that zero
five five must have existed is that its
containment chamber existed
according to the official records kept
by the foundation on the site-19
containment facilities
zero five five is kept in a five by five
by 2.5 meter Square Room constructed a
50-foot thick cement with a faraday cage
surrounding the cement walls the report
continues that access is via a heavy
containment door measuring 2 by 2.5
meters constructed on bearings to ensure
door closes and locks automatically
unless held open deliberately
zero five five cell is one of the few to
have no posted security guards and any
Personnel working on other scps in the
area are ordered to remain at least 50
feet from the geometric Center of zero
five five cell
where the anomaly itself is capped when
he tried to explore further why the cell
was constructed in this manner he found
that surprise surprise nobody knew zero
five five was an anomaly whose
containment requirements were so
mysterious that it automatically netted
itself a ketter class designation after
all how can you properly contain
something you can't even hope to
comprehend there were plenty of rumors
about the true nature of 055
some of the more conspiratorial Minds at
site 19 theorized that 055 was actually
an autonomous or remotely controlled spy
inserted into the site to observe
Foundation operations or even Humanity
as a whole if you're on the more
paranoid end of the psychological
Spectrum this Theory makes total sense
an anomaly that's physically impossible
to remember even when writings and
pictures on the subject exist would be a
perfect spy however this was all
ultimately little more than speculation
Walter was barely any further along than
when he started there were multiple
points in his investigations where
Walter seriously considered giving up
until finally he had a major
breakthrough Dr Bartholomew Hughes and
Dr John marichek were two scientists
that had performed extensive research
into zero five five and who Walter hoped
might have the answers he sought about
the self-keeping secret these scientists
were the first to discover the
anti-memetic nature of 0.055 performing
numerous tests on d-class Personnel to
see if it was possible to create
feasible written records sketches or any
other records or Impressions that could
bypass its anomalous effects the
disorienting memory ruining effects of
055 also extend to any materials
concerning 055 it seems to be a truly
uncrackable code but Dr Hughes may have
finally found some cracks in the armor
for starters the fact that we're able to
remember that 055 is an anti-memetic is
an ironic exception to its anti-memetic
qualities this Revelation also inspired
another realization from Dr Hughes
would it be possible to discover more
about 055 from the process of deduction
rather than the typical induction in
other words could they possibly learn
about zero five five by figuring out all
the things it isn't rather than what it
is Dr marichek designed an experiment
with Dr Hughes to explore this Theory
they designed the experiment around a
simple question is 055 not spherical in
designing the question to specifically
find out what 055 isn't they hope to
subvert the anomaly's anti-memetic
powers Walter was fascinated by this
potential method of getting answers
marichek and Hughes found that while the
questioning process for those exposed
was often arduous and frustrating
they could now definitely say that 055
is not a sphere it is theoretically
possible to discover the true nature of
055 by an almost endless barrage of
deductive questions though whether
command would authorize the resources
for such extensive testing is still an
open question Walter and his desperation
begged marichek and Hughes for clearance
to view zero five five himself the
Curiosity had become too great during a
search to just walk away with the single
fact that 055 was in spherical he needed
to see this thing and after several
weeks of filling out forms and cutting
red tape his wish was finally granted
Walter Bainbridge was allowed a private
audience with
scp-055 the subject of his month's long
Obsession Outsiders observe that Walter
spent just over an hour in the
containment chamber taking photos
drawing sketches writing down notes
recording audio logs and reciting memory
mnemonics he was pulling out every stop
to counteract the anti-memetic effects
of the self-keeping secret he was
adamant that he would not be defeated by
his non-spherical Nemesis not after all
this time and effort once his time in
the 055 containment chamber was over he
retired back to his office to finally
digitize his exhaustive findings so that
his supervisor Mr Kovach would finally
get off his back Walter smiled to deep
breath and began to type
scp-059 cutter class this anomaly is a
radioactive mineral that emits a unique
radiation known as Delta radiation
exposure to this radiation has caused
strange fungal growth on the infected
wait what was this supposed to be about
again oh well it couldn't have been that
important in an old house an old woman
gathers her knitting supplies this is a
special project for a little boy named
Tommy she loves dearly she knits
furiously and soon the mix of cotton
synthetic fiber and cloth of every color
turn from raw materials into something
else a teddy bear she puts the finishing
touches on the bear this is a very
special bear after all and since the
patchwork bear off to its destination
with a red get well card the card is
labeled karos the bear and inside she
writes a personal note to Tommy because
only time can mend all wounds love
Grammy but this package of Love would
never reach its destination
scp-2295 was found at the site of a
crashed mail truck and it looks exactly
like a standard handmade teddy bear with
one difference on the left side of its
chest just under its jaunty tan bow it
wears a heart-shaped pin but not as
standard cartoon heart this is a
disturbingly realistic anatomically
correct pin of a heart organ and that's
because
scp-2295 has a specific purpose and it's
one that has everything to do with
actual human organs
scp-2295 spends most of its time
completely inert spending its days as
just another cuddly stuffed toy Tess
performed on the toy revealed that it
had no unusual properties and seems to
be a normal handmade Keepsake that is
until someone is injured in its presence
not any injury will do a paper cut or
even a broken arm for example won't do
much to activate its anomalous
properties but if it detects a critical
injury to a human organ nearby it will
trigger a secret power one that the
foundation is still trying to figure out
how it works because
scp-2295 is a miracle worker when it
senses the presence of someone with a
serious injury to an organ and is within
two meters of them
scp-2295 Springs into action suddenly
from unknown sources the bear will
produce objects including scissors white
thread and sewing needles or a
crocheting hook from its mouth if there
are any crafting supplies on hand it
will incorporate those as well and then
it gets to work despite only having
hands made of fabric and stuffing with
no fingers the anomalous Bearer is still
able to craft what will end up being a
patchwork Recreation of the damaged
humans organ cute if a little creepy but
that's just the beginning the injured
person mysteriously Falls unconscious
and the patchwork organ which the
foundation has designated as
scp-2295-1 instance will disappear the
scp-2295-1 instance will then physically
replace the damaged organ inside the
person's body it's unknown how this
happens the patchwork organ will simply
appear inside of their body taking the
place of the original lung or kidney or
whichever organ was found feeling it's
unknown where the original organ goes to
since it seems to just disappear as soon
as the 2295-1 instance takes its place
surprisingly having this new cotton
stuffed harder liver does not seem to
cause any harm and in fact it works
exactly like the real thing there are
never any of the usual issues that come
with a transplant like the risk of it
being rejected by the body as the
organic tissue seems to have no issue
connecting with the organ and treating
it like it was there all along in all
instances of scp-2295 Performing this
adorable but rudimentary surgery the
subjects have made a full and complete
recovery
scp-2295 might sound like a miracle
worker but that isn't to say that its
abilities aren't without their own set
of complications when faced with two
injured subjects
scp-2295 seems to always gravitate
towards fixing the younger subject up
first maybe owing to its creation by a
grandmother who wanted to heal whatever
was ailing her grandson no one knows who
Tommy was or exactly what disease or
injury he was recovering from but his
grandmother clearly felt it was serious
enough to create this special bear for
him while scp-2295 will heal anyone it
seems to be primarily a guardian for the
young and it takes its duties very
seriously even to the point of
self-sacrifice while
scp-2295 is able to pull some of its
supplies out of thin air it still always
needs some raw materials to craft the
new organ including Fabric and stuffing
and if there are none available as
cp2295 will obtain them the hard way the
patchwork bear will sacrifice its own
body tearing itself open and removing
any Fabric or stuffing it needs without
any concern for its own well-being in
order to craft a new organ for its
patient it slowly regenerates its own
stuffing at the rate of around a gram of
stuffing per day but it needs to harvest
fabric to repair its outer layer which
the Foundation happily makes available
to it offering it a variety of patterns
and types it's no surprise that a teddy
bear capable of healing mortal wounds
would be of great interest to the SCP
Foundation and as soon as it was
recovered from the crash mail truck they
immediately began tests to find out more
about it could it heal literally any
organ were there any limits to its
abilities there was only one way to find
out and the foundation had the perfect
test subjects d-class Personnel whose
interactions with non-cuddly teddy bear
scps frequently left them with critical
external and internal injuries the first
test subject brought in
d2353 a 38 year old man who was in poor
health not due to his work as a d-class
Personnel but from his years and years
of heavy smoking his lungs were
seriously damaged which gave him trouble
breathing and made any serious physical
exertion extremely difficult he wasn't
critically injured or in danger of dying
immediately but that didn't matter to
scp-2295
d2353 quickly passed out and the bear
sprang into action it proceeded to take
two textile swatches one black and one
red and create a pair of fabric lungs
which had installed in the patient when
he awoke
d-2353 found he had full healthy lung
function again as if he never picked up
his deadly habit but now the foundation
researchers needed to know how
scp-2295 would do with even more
complicated ailments
d-3542 was 50 years old and his heart
was not in good shape not only did he
have a serious case of atherosclerosis
which is a disease where cholesterol
plaque builds up and blocks blood flow
and can put you at serious risk of a
heart attack but he also had an
irregular heartbeat this d-class was in
bad shape but that was no problem for
scp-2295 who took a collection of
different different colors of yarn and a
crochet hook and created a plushy heart
just like the lungs had acted as if they
were completely regular organs after the
heart anomalously ended up inside the
man's chest it began to beat normally
and performed all the complicated
functions of a human heart but there was
one detail that shocked the unlooking
doctors before the yarn organ had
vanished the doctors had seen that it
was beating so is there any organ that
scp-2295 can't replace that was about to
be tested when d-7894 was brought in a
24 year old woman she had suffered
serious Burns all over her torso left
abdomen and right leg she was brought in
and sedated to numb the agonizing pain
and researchers were worried that they
had come up against the limit of
scp-2295's abilities since the skin is
the largest organ after all but scp-2295
wasn't phased at all the bear
immediately started sewing segments of
patch work Fabric and layering them onto
the damaged skin replacing the dermis
and epidermis layer by layer unlike the
other cases these replacement organs are
visible and d7894 now has Patchwork skin
just like her talented surgeon and
amazingly the fabric has the same sense
of touch that a regular skin did the
final test of
scp-2295's abilities came with d2723 who
is only 18 years old this last minute
d-class test was performed because he
was showing signs of severe cerebral
hemorrhage the kind that would cause
brain damage in only minutes and would
be followed soon after by complete brain
death
scp-2295 sprung to life but as soon as
it examined the test subject it became
distressed it started frantically
grasping at random material around it as
if it didn't know what to do with them
then it reached inside itself and
provided a large chocolate bar which it
offered to the subject sadly to no
effect it then seemed to admit defeat as
it grabbed tightly onto the subject's
leg observers reported that it was
leaking a tear-like solution from its
small knitted eyes as it embraced the
dying d-class in his final moments sadly
it seems that the human brain is the one
mystery that even
scp-2295 can't solve
scp-2295 appears to pose no threat to
anyone and was classified as safe after
testing it is inactive when not in the
presence of an injured person and has
never displayed hostile instincts when
active the foundation determined that it
should be stored in a standard
containment Locker in site-37 where it
can be kept safely until it's needed for
tests or to repair an injured SCP
Personnel access is limited to those
with level 3 or higher security
clearance and any contact with a bear is
highly regulated but there is one
element of
scp-2295's existence that continues to
worry foundations staff
scp-2295's full Origins and the
grandmother who crafted it are unknown
the note it was found with is the only
clue as to where it may have come from
but there are plenty within the
foundation who are suspicious of the
veracity of this letter and they have
good reason not to be too trusting
because another bear with similar
abilities exists and it is distinctly
less benevolent than a scp-2295
scp-1048 is also a teddy bear but it is
capable of moving on its own and
communicating through gestures at all
times it was initially allowed to wander
around independently and seemed to make
its home at site-24 a happier place but
then it began to display its own
crafting abilities
scp-1048 is able to craft duplicates of
itself and while the original was
seemingly harmless the ones it made were
not these similarly shaped bears were
made of disturbing materials and were
extreme extremely hostile towards any
humans they encountered the first
scp-1048-a was made entirely out of
human ears and when it shrieked it
caused anyone nearby to generate
ear-like growths all over their bodies
eventually causing them to suffocate the
creature disappeared and an on-site
researcher was found to be missing an
ear the creations of scp-1048 only got
stranger and deadlier from there
scp-1048-b was found in the sites
cafeteria where it was moving around in
a halted jerky fashion it then started
bursting at the seams and revealed what
appeared to be a human fetus inside when
the creature screamed it sounded like a
much louder version of a human infant
and its crows caused Massive Internal
damage to anyone around it
scp-1048-b was killed in the ensuing
conflict with Foundation agents ending
its threat but scp-1048 was learning
deadlier techniques when scp-104 48-c
was discovered it looked to be a teddy
bear made entirely out of Rusty scrap
metal when it was spotted by Dr Carver
and targeted by Foundation Personnel the
creature turned violent and proved to
have Incredible strength jumping through
the agents who were trying to neutralize
it tearing through their bodies like
tissue paper attempts to damage it were
unsuccessful and both it and the bear
made out of ears are still on the loose
along with the original
scp-1048 capturing it is Major priority
for the foundation because no one wants
to see what it will create next is there
a connection between these two very
different teddy bears no one has been
able to answer this question the origins
of scp-1048 are unknown and so is any
connection to the mysterious grandmother
who may have made karos the bear but
their abilities are similar with both
able to craft living objects out of
seemingly any material they just have
very different ideas as to what a good
use of their crafting abilities are it
is fortunate that an anomaly is
potentially powerful as
scp-2295 seems to only want one thing to
help those in need especially those who
are the most vulnerable does life
imitate art or does art imitate life
it's a question that has been asked
throughout human history this
philosophical debate is about the ways
art either reflects the world around us
or influences it but in the case of
scp-085 the idea of art imitating life
takes on a far more literal meaning this
entity was created during an experiment
involving two separate scps the first of
these was
scp-067 which is a fountain pen that
when held by a user will take full
control of the person's hand and arm
scp-067 then either writes about or
draws something linked to the user
holding it the second of these scps was
scp-914 better known as the Clock Works
this massive piece of anomalous
Machinery will have various effects
depending on what or who is placed
inside of it and which of its several
settings is chosen on the selection
panel after test subject 1101f was given
the anomalous fountain pen the result on
the page was a simple female figure
around 6 inches tall and 1.5 inches wide
She was drawn wearing a summer dress
with her long hair tie back in a
ponytail and a single word was written
underneath her Cassandra as part of the
experiment the drawing was placed inside
of scp-914 and the fine settings
selected this is the setting that is
known to improve the object placed
inside of it in some way for example a
hunk of Steel placed inside will be
transformed into a pile of Steel carp
attacks a refined version of the steel
when the drawing was placed inside
something truly amazing happened
Cassandra came to life or as she now
prefers to be called Cassie
scp-085 sometimes known as hand-drawn
Cassie is a completely sentient being
she is fully able to communicate however
it all has to be done non-verbally her
voice cannot be heard by anyone beyond
the page Where She was drawn but she is
able to utilize sign language or create
writings on the page in order to
communicate with Foundation researchers
scp-085 has been shown to also be
capable of understanding text that is
written on the same paper she exists on
she is fully animated aware of her own
existence and the limitations of being
two-dimensional in nature according to
profiling conducted by the SCP
Foundation she has her own distinct
personality Cassie is good-natured and
agreeable displaying a natural drive and
motivation but also seems to feel the
burden of loneliness living in solitude
on the page it should be noted that any
and all attempts to recreate the same
experiment that formed scp-085 had
failed to create the same or similar
results tragically Cassie might be the
only one of her kind in existence a
creation of pure luck with no chance of
making another no wonder she feels so
lonely while Cassie is limited to her
two-dimensional form and has so far been
unable to enter our three-dimensional
world she has demonstrated several
different abilities on the page firstly
she is not solely confined to the same
paper She was drawn on
scp-085 is able to transfer herself from
sheet to sheet if another page is placed
flush with hers she will be able to
Simply step across onto this new page
however there is a limit to what kind of
page Cassie is able to transfer herself
onto she could easily take a stroll
through the pages of today's newspaper
but can't just wander onto someone's
family photos or anything made of
cardboard glass or parchment for that
matter
scp-085 can only exist on paper or
canvas and only when they are directly
connected to her original page according
to Foundation testing this is not
exclusive to blank pieces of paper
either if Cassie ever transfers herself
onto a page bearing a repeated pattern
like a piece of wallpaper then she will
appear to be in the foreground while
everything else on the paper appears to
be behind her
scp-085 will perceive each page she
enters as a completely new place from
her point of view pattern Pages seem to
be like endless space additionally
Cassie can also travel to other pieces
of artwork and adopt the same art style
of each new environment she appears in
for example transferring yourself onto
the pages of a comic book will cause
Cassie to be rendered in an artistic
manner matching that of her surroundings
the same occurs if she travels to an oil
painting watercolor or charcoal sketch
interestingly when appearing in comic
book form Cassie's thoughts and speech
are visible through thought bubbles that
are commonly used to display text within
the comic medium her size and the angle
she is viewed from also changes to match
the different panels of the comic page
she is on at one point scp-085 was
introduced by Foundation Personnel to a
print copy of ascending and descending
by the famous Dutch artist M.C Escher
this painting is of a large building
with its roof consisting of a looped
never-ending staircase when she
transferred onto the print of escher's
painting scp-085 curiously explored her
new environment and was able to ascend
and descend the staircase the researcher
gave Cassie the name of the piece and
asked for her thoughts on it she
remarked it's pretty I guess would make
a neat exercise track when the
researcher asked if she noticed anything
inconsistent about the staircase Cassie
replied no as far as I can tell it just
loops around down up all the time why
don't more staircases do that it's
pretty neat following this Cassie
directly requested more impossible
objects or optical illusions to be drawn
onto her page and made part of her
environment unfortunately her request is
still pending review from the o5 council
being able to step from page to page
transferring yourself onto canvas or
sheets of papers but one of
scp-085's unique abilities she can also
interact with other drawn objects on the
same page she is on if someone draws an
item of clothing on her page or a
vehicle even food or drink then Cassie
would be able to wear use or consume
those objects drawn for her behave as if
they were real but only when Cassie is
directly interacting with them the rest
of the time they remain still just as
they were drawn once scp-085 touches
them these items will animate this same
rule even applies to anything drawn to
depict something in motion for example
trees being blown in the wind or the
waves of an ocean these will also stay
perfectly still when drawn and only move
when acted upon by
scp-085 however much like her ability to
transfer from page to page Cassie's hour
over other two-dimensional drawings has
limits drawing anything that would
normally be an inanimate object within
the real world will provide scp-085
something that she can directly interact
with but this doesn't appear to be the
case for living beings like another
person or an animal that would have its
own autonomy and freedom of movement in
our three-dimensional reality animals
and people drawn for Cassie to interact
with will remain as static unmoving
drawings and will not become animated
like she is even if drawn using scp-067
she cannot impart any of her own
sentience or free will onto these
drawings and they remain still even when
she touches them you might think that
drawings of other people whether they
are animated or not might help alleviate
Cassie's solitude but if anything it
just reminds her how alone she is SCP
Foundation researchers have noted that
scp-085 is very friendly towards them
and any subjects brought in to conduct
experiments with her visits from the
three-dimensional World outside the page
she inhabits seems to offer some relief
to Cassie's loneliness through much of
her behavior she has shown a fascination
with our reality and in particular she
has an interest in cars expressing that
she wishes she had an ability to work on
them this desire appears to be
completely genuine too as shown when her
photo was taken with scp-978 the camera
that reveals its subject's inner desires
and in Cassie's case showed her in a
fully realized 3D version of herself
working on a car
scp-085's curiosity about the world
beyond the page is most likely due to
how different it is from her everyday
two-dimensional existence but on at
least one occasion Cassie's curiosity
got the better of her and
unintentionally led to a Containment
Breach from the moment she was first
drawn to life and even after her initial
testing with researchers
scp-085 seemed unaware that she was a
two-dimensional being in a
three-dimensional World Foundation
security protocol calls regarding
scp-085 meant that no one on the
research team assigned to Cassie was
permitted to tell her the truth about
her 2D nature the truth about her
existence was kept from her with the
best of intentions as research staff did
not want to cause scp-085 any undue
distress or trigger a possible
psychological snap anything that Cassie
raised as an inconsistency or
discrepancy within her world on the page
was explained by researchers to be the
result of Her Imagination or dreams and
research Personnel attempted to convince
scp-085 that she was in a scenario
wherein she was the only human Survivor
searching for others in a
post-apocalyptic environment however
misguided this decision to conceal the
truth might have been it was at least
done with Cassie's best interests at
heart but a lie as they say is harder to
maintain than the truth and keeping
scp-085 in the dark about her true
nature arguably led her to more hardship
that may have been avoided if she had
been allowed to know the truth in the
incident in question a foundation
researcher entered the room where the
drawing pad that Cassie resides in was
found and they were carrying a paper
copy of scp-085's special containment
procedures report given that she had
already partaken in tests where she had
transferred herself to other paper and
canvas surfaces Cassie assumed that this
file was yet another new environment for
her to explore the researcher allowed
scp-085 to make direct contact with the
report and she was able to transfer over
to the document before the researcher
realized their mistake whether this
occurred accidentally or if this
researcher intended to confront Cassie
with the truth about what she was is
unknown nevertheless Cassie found
herself on the pages of her own SCP
Foundation file the record of every test
the research staff had conducted a full
description of how she had first been
drawn by scp-067 and brought to life by
scp-914 all clear as day in black and
white Cassie's own true nature was
presented to her immediately the Yarns
that Foundation researchers had spun
about her surviving an apocalypse began
to unravel was all a lie meant to keep
her in the dark and prevent her from
ever knowing that she was trapped in two
Dimensions she returned to her original
page shortly later but the damage was
already done due to her having breached
containment and briefly escaped into her
own file the number of foundation
researchers proposed that scp-085 be
destroyed there was always a risk of
this happening again what would happen
if Cassie unwittingly found herself
inside another file with access to more
of the foundation's sensitive
information however the o5 council
decreed that scp-085 was not to be
terminated allowing Cassie to continue
to exist despite the breach ever since
she learned the truth about herself
signs of depression have begun to
manifest in her behavior finding out you
are a drawing trapped in two Dimensions
with no chance of ever having someone
else for company would be enough to
crush anyone's Spirit but luckily
researchers have since managed to uplift
Cassie a little and offer her a welcome
distraction from her unfortunate
Revelation the optical illusions like
the never-ending staircase she requested
were quickly drawn into her environment
additionally given the interest she had
shown in the technical drawing of a 1964
Ford Mustang convertible
scp-085 had been allowed to assemble a
car for her own by transferring each
individual component of the car from the
blueprint to her page hand-drawn Cassie
had been gradually building her very own
Mustang to keep herself preoccupied from
her life in cartoon motion and in the
end if she can distract herself and find
that tiny bit of happiness isn't that
all that matters in the sense we're all
trapped within our own Dimension Cassian
or 2d1 us in our 3D World filling our
lives with hobbies and entertainment all
in an effort to make sure that we never
tug too hard at the threads of our
reality and find out there just might be
much more out there that were missing we
hope you're ready folks because today
we're discussing the most dangerous SCP
of all time we know you've probably
heard this before but seriously this one
is the absolute top of the Pyramid of
fear or the fear amid if you will this
SCP makes 682 weep in Terror for its
life it makes the old man
scp-106 consider turning his life around
and taking up a career in humanitarian
work it even makes the dreaded Scarlet
King himself the Lord of chaos the
ultimate despair quake in his spiky red
boots it's just that utterly terrifying
just kidding it's Lego but we had you
going there for a second didn't we
though it may not actually be the
scariest anomaly of all time
scp-387 isn't your granddad's Lego set
either unless your granddad goes by
agent Hardy and works for the SCP
Foundation Hardy is one of the hundreds
of thousands of foundation field agents
planted all over the globe in every
thing from law enforcement to
surveillance ever watchful for the kinds
of anomalies the SCP Foundation makes it
their mission to secure contain and
protect but when he discovered scp-387
he wasn't even technically on duty he
was taking a long train journey home
from his parents house while his car was
in the shop and as anyone who's ever
taken a long train journey knows without
proper stimulation boredom will crop up
in no time he'd been reading a pretty
interesting book on his e-reader when
tragedy first struck and it ran out of
battery Hardy had forgotten to bring his
charging cable so he was potentially
looking at another three hours of
mind-numbing monotony that's when he
noticed the red plastic tub that had
been apparently abandoned in the seat
across from him he realized in that
moment that had been there the whole
time unsupervised given that he was a
foundation field agent and was as such
extremely curious he grabbed the tub and
took a look inside hoping to find
something that'll quell his growing
boredom lucky for him the box was full
of Lego bricks everyone's favorite brand
of toy construction block the tub was
brimming with a vast collection of
pieces some of which like wheels and
prisms agent Hardy had never seen before
despite spending his childhood
obsessively making Lego constructions
but Hardy wasn't one to criticize a gift
from the universe this tub of Lego
pieces would be the perfect way to keep
himself entertained for the rest of his
long journey he spent the next hour or
so meticulously recreating site 19 in
Lego form on the table in front of him
when the building was done he decided to
have some fun and populate the site with
a collection of Lego men standing in for
SCP Foundation scientists containment
Specialists and guards after finding a
torso with a lab coat in the Box agent
Hardy decided to make a tiny Doctor
Bright to start with however as soon as
he made the tiny Lego scientists and set
it down on his new site-19 playset he
realized that everything was not as
innocently typical as it seemed the
little man instant Lee began to walk
immediately picking up a tiny Lego
clipboard and heading towards the Euclid
containment Wing agent Hardy had
discovered a brand new anomaly on his
day off while playing with toys on a
boring train ride philosopher LP Jax was
certainly right when he said a master in
The Art of Living draws no sharp
distinction between his work and his
play naturally agent Hardy immediately
took the little Lego Man Apart along
with his sight 19 simulacrum and alerted
his superiors at the SCP Foundation his
co-workers met him at the next train
stop platform not long after the box of
seemingly living Lego pieces
redesignated
scp-387 was in the hands of foundation
researcher Dr Arch his first priority
was finding out what exactly they were
all dealing with here whether there was
more of it out there and whether it was
dangerous attempts to investigate the
origins of scp-387 were mostly fruitless
undercover Foundation agents
investigated every Lego producing
location they could find but found no
evidence of anything similar to 387
being produced and of course as with
anything that seemed to be an anomalous
toy all possible links to Dr
wondertainment were also explored but
again nothing came up this was probably
for the best if 387 was a doctor
wondertainment product it probably would
have built itself into an actual sized
dinosaur and started eating people
already all further investigations into
387's Origins were subsequently dropped
with background research turning out to
be a dead end Dr Arch decided to get
down to business doing the fun part
actual experimentation after Gathering
all the proper permissions from his
superiors the testing commenced in
experiment 387-a Dr Arch recruited a
number of Lego loving d-classes after
all even convicted robbers arsonists and
murderers love Lego and made them
construct a little Lego Community inside
a testing chamber this consisted of a
small Main Street with a number of Lego
stores a residential area and the bar as
soon as the d-classes constructed a
variety of little Lego men and released
them into the community they instantly
came to life and began performing their
roles perfectly some took up jobs in the
various stores cafes and boutiques
others acted as patrons for the
different businesses the Lego men were
even noted as forming rudimentary family
units one man did fall into the river in
this Lego City but otherwise things were
going smoothly encouraged by these
developments Dr Arch was ready to begin
the true experiment introducing a
complex new variable into the
environment of the Lego man and seeing
exactly how they reacted he had another
d-class build the commercial airliner
out of normal non-anomalous Lego bricks
and place it just to the side of the
Lego community over the following three
hour period Dr Arch observed the Lego
man engaging in some truly remarkable
Behavior upon noticing the plane the
Lego man began to form a plan they first
procured the necessary equipment from
the scp-387 Hub and headed over to the
plane for A Hard Day's Work in Lego man
time at least with remarkable efficiency
the citizens of the Lego Community began
forming a fully functional airport
around the plain multiple runways an air
traffic control tower and even a mall
and food court within the airport itself
tiny Lego attendants tried to sell
perfume to uninterested Lego commuters
and Lego TSA agents Frist uncomfortable
would-bead Lego passengers its accuracy
to the real-life airport experience was
truly brilliant but they didn't stop
there a tiny Lego fuel truck sped over
to the plane and acted out the process
of refueling it a Lego pilot and his
Lego co-pilot climbed into the plane and
it took off literally flying around the
room without any kind of logical
propulsion system Dr Arch was amazed and
even then they didn't stop they
continued to build more planes of
various makes and models resulting in a
sprawling airport that if you squinted
would look just like the real thing from
this stock Dr Arch concluded that the
387 Lego man had the ability to convert
non-anomalous Lego pieces into anomalous
ones he proceeded to the next experiment
for experiment 387-b Dr Arch decided to
switch up the d-classes and instead
brought in some of LEGO's more
traditional target audience a group of
10 year old children they began building
some basic instructions out of the
pieces their typical buildings people
and cars but when they realized that
their Creations were actually alive
their tune immediately changed the kids
spoken hushed excited tones About a new
plan and then began putting it into
practice they built functional
Transformers and just to be clear it
wasn't electrical Transformers they
crafted we're talking Transformers as an
actual Optimus Prime and Megatron an M1
Abrams tank in a number of different
Lego weapons of mass destruction Dr Arch
was mortified realizing that he'd
apparently gathered up a team of budding
childhood super villains and had them
removed from the test chamber from
gymnastic treatment immediately however
the second the test chamber was vacated
the kids Creations came to life and
entered a state of all-out War it was an
intense battle lasting about an hour and
left no Lego survivors just a huge mess
around the room while this test was
largely an embarrassment for all
involved it did lead to some interesting
new data Not only was this anomaly safe
in the sense that it didn't pose a
Containment Breach it was also safe in
the more colloquial sense there was no
way these Lego bricks could hurt you
unless you decided to eat them and
choked don't do that by the way we see
you don't
scp-387 is unable to perform dangerous
actions if humans of any age are present
in the vicinity and this arrangement
goes both ways too the Lego Creations
will be alive and to some extent
sentient if played with peacefully
however if the human playing with them
becomes hostile then they will
immediately become inanimate so play
nice folks next game experiment 380 7-c
and experiment 387-c2 where Dr Arch
turned his attention to the tub itself
since scp-387 came into the foundation's
possession the quantity of 387 blocks
had increased how is this possible
you're probably wondering Dr Arch and
his team discovered an interesting
phenomena when some of the scp-387 is
placed back in the red tub but the Red
Tub isn't filled then 387 will
self-duplicate to fill out the tub much
like the way a gas will disperse to fill
out any containment unit it finds itself
inside however Dr Arch also discovered
some interesting limitations there
seemed to be no inherent anomalous
qualities to the Red Tub itself during
one of the experimentations Dr Arch half
filled the red tub with non-anomalous
Lego pieces and found that nothing
changed similarly he performed another
experiment where he placed a single
scp-387 brick into the box and found
there was no difference when he came
back Dr Arch and his associates came to
the conclusion that the anomalous
properties are confined solely to the
bricks themselves but they have a kind
of symbiotic relationship with the Red
Tub as they don't replicate in any other
containment units in order to activate
replication the 387 must cover the
entire bottom layer of the tub next came
experiment 387--d where Dr Arch hoped to
test the specific activation mechanisms
of scp-387 the Lego Creations animated
whenever they were assembled by a child
or an adult so it wasn't an
age-regulated anomaly the next
experiment involved using a remotely
controlled robotic arm to create a Lego
construction to see if the mere Act of
construction itself was enough to
instigate 387's primary anomalous effect
however this didn't turn out to be the
case the robotic arm assembled Lego
construction never came alive Dr Arch's
next hypothesis was that perhaps flesh
was needed to activate
scp-387 but how could he test using
Flash without just having a normal human
assemble the Lego pieces thankfully the
answer came to Dr Arch by total accident
a few cells over an anomaly trying to
breach containment had just killed a
foundation agent trying to stand in its
way while the d-classes cleaned up the
mess Dr Arch dragged the body over to
where the 387 tests were being conducted
and meticulously puppeteered its arms
and hands to put together more 387 Lego
constructions but once again it didn't
come to life interesting next hypothesis
maybe it needs warmth to activate in a
move that proved unpopular with
co-workers just trying to eat their
pre-packaged sandwiches in the site-19
break room Dr Arch dragged the dead
Foundation agent's body over towards the
room's radiator and leaned its arms and
hands over the top of it for 20 minutes
before giving his newly discovered
puppeteering skills another go but once
again nothing happened Dr Arch concluded
that perhaps human psychic energy or
maybe an active pulse was what caused
387 to activate if you're waiting for
the horrifying twist well aside from the
puppeteering of a dead co-worker's limbs
we're pleased to tell you that there
just isn't one this time
scp-387 serves no containment for each
risk and no risk of harm to Foundation
Personnel in fact playing with the
living Lego has led to an 87 increase in
morale for foundation staff so as long
as you fill in the proper forms and tidy
up afterwards you're actually allowed to
play with the scp-387 anytime you want
after all working for the SCP Foundation
is a stressful job and really we're all
children at heart oh and there was one
more experiment experiment 387-e where a
Lego Community was built using scp-387
and then a pile of Mega Blocks Lego's
most common imitator was introduced into
the mix the Lego man of the community
really weren't pleased by this while the
actual details of what happened have
thankfully been expunged the one clue to
what may have happened came from a note
left by Dr Arch that's right the
Puppeteer guy his notes on that
experiment were four simple words oh no
not again the year was 1857 and the
second Opium War was raging between
China and the combined forces of the
English and French it was one of the
many bloody colonial wars fought over
resources like tea sugar and the
intoxicating Opium poppy it was a war
fought by peasants and noblemen alike
one of these aristocratic soldiers was
the noble Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood
the quintessential English gentleman and
Explorer while his fellow soldiers
cowered behind cover Lord Blackwood
charged Into The Fray shouldering his
rifle and firing his pistol into the
crowd of opposing soldiers it was the
Battle of Canton one of the most crucial
battles of the entire conflict the
French and English were laying Siege to
the City of Canton also known as
Guangzhou to prove their military
dominance and capture an important
Chinese government official Lord
Blackwood led the charge on Horseback
every bullet seemed to find the heart of
a foe he was a true hero among men a
gentleman warrior with class refinement
and style and it would be thanks to his
expert leadership and Marksmanship on
the field that the Allied European
forces won the battle decisively Lord
Theodore Thomas Blackwood is a name that
deserves to be counted among Lord
Horatio Nelson Sir Francis Bacon and Sir
Walter Raleigh in addition to being a
skilled and honorable fighter Lord
Blackwood is a consummate Explorer
naturalist and Frontiersman during his
Heyday he traveled perhaps further than
any man across the known and unknown
corners of the globe he made scientific
biological and anthropological
discoveries that should have reset the
course of society forever and yet you
won't find any records in the history
books of Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood
nor will you find any Grand oil
paintings or dedicated Wings in British
museums this is because Lord Theodore
Thomas Blackwood is a four and a half
inch telepathic neon C Slug and he's
known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-1867 while he would never admit to
it Lord Blackwood belongs to the species
nambrother kubariana also known as the
variable neon slug he's kept in a
standard aquarium in a foundation
containment site and is physically no
different to any other member of his
species what makes Lord Blackwood unique
is his powerful telepathic abilities
specifically the power to communicate by
speaking directly into people's minds
and what's more he's extremely talkative
but to what extent is anything that this
anomalous sea slug says true or is he
just like scp-082 Ferdinand the cannibal
a creative and pathological liar it
isn't committed to record how exactly
the foundation discovered Lord Blackwood
perhaps a local aquarium worker worried
they were going insane when they heard
the voice of a 19th century English
nobleman ringing in their ears when
whenever they were cleaning algae out of
the tank maybe Lord Blackwood was found
by SCP Foundation divers were constantly
combing the ocean for anomalous
creatures and activity what we do know
is that Lord Blackwood is an incredibly
strange and mysterious individual he
claims to have visited locations all
around the world and encountered rare
societies and creatures the foundation
was skeptical about a number of Lord
blackwood's more outlandish claims on
account of him being a sea slug but he
does appear to have the knowledge to
back up his supposed experience
interviews with Lord Blackwood have
shown that he's extremely knowledgeable
in the areas of geography zoology botany
archeology anthropology and Linguistics
relating to his claim regions of
exploration as well as more esoteric
Fields such as obscure mythology
mysticism and cryptozoology in other
words if Lord Blackwood hadn't gone on
his escapades around the globe
throughout history how would he have
come to possess this wide variety of of
information the foundation was getting
frustrated and began to probe further
into the personal life of the most
interesting gastropod in containment
Lord Blackwood under questioning was
always polite and amicable with
Foundation staff he seemed to display no
real knowledge of the fact that he
himself was a sea slug going as far to
accuse other people of being crazy or
drunk when they brought the fact up to
him while none of Lord blackwood's tall
tales ever extend past the year 1910. he
told fanciful stories of exploring the
Americas and of his involvement in the
second Opium War on the side of the
English naturally the foundation wanted
proof when they pressured Lord Blackwood
on this something even stranger happened
he gave it the Lord told his
interviewers that he would happily
donate his collection to them if it gave
them cause to believe what he was saying
he gave the baffled Foundation
researchers the address of a cottage in
England where they could find the
secrets to his bizarre and mysterious
past and local agents in the area have
followed up on the information upon
investigation Foundation field agents
did indeed find the cottage that Lord
Blackwood had specified it was being
maintained by an extremely old woman
when questioned about her presence there
she said that she was keeping the house
for Lord Blackwood and gave no more
useful information incidentally it
appears that this singular purpose was
all that this old woman was living for
she abruptly passed away from heart
failure five days after the foundation
commandeered the cottage whether
anything truly anomalous caused this we
still do not know at first the cottage
seemed normal until the field agents
discovered a secret basement housing
Lord blackwood's collection they were
amazed at what they saw the basement
consisted of Zoological and Botanical
specimens over 3000 artifacts a library
containing over 5 000 items and a
functioning 1800s scientific laboratory
it took about three weeks for foundation
agents working Round the Clock in shifts
to remove all the items from Lord
blackwood's mysterious collection and
what they found raised even more
questions the collection included but
was no means limited to 116 unknown
species of plants 107 unknown species of
insects 28 unknown species of lizards 23
unknown species of fish 14 unknown
species of amphibians 12 unknown species
of mammals fossils pertaining to eight
unknown species of dinosaur fossils
pertaining to 12 unknown species of
prehistoric mammal and artifacts
belonging to 29 unknown indigenous
societies that's a lot of unknowns but
wait there's more his collection also
contained a collection of seemingly
unknown Firearms including three wide
bore muskets marked as Dr b t moth's
effective particle destabilizers
detailed Globes of Mercury Venus Mars
and the Galilean moons accompanied by
notes detailing possible Paths of
surface exploration a heavily modified
Carriage containing instruments of
unknown purpose a note attached to the
door reads on the Frets speak with Henry
and a highly dangerous and seemingly
anomalous machine that killed four
Foundation field agents before it was
destroyed on site and when questioned
about this little Fiasco Lord Blackwood
responded I did warn you to be careful
around my collection that bloody thing
nearly took my head off back in 97 when
I found it however there was one thing
recovered from Lord blackwood's
collection that was perhaps more
interesting than all the others 35
handwritten journals containing
recordings of events described by Lord
Blackwood in his grandiose Tall Tales to
the foundation researchers the accounts
are generally identical to the stories
he had told save for some slight
variations and exaggerations on the part
of Blackwood in the retelling most
interestingly of all all of these
journals have been dated to the
appropriate time period of the events
described by Foundation scientists while
his stories are too numerous to all be
sure shared here there's one that
perfectly sums them all up Lord
blackwood's account of a possible
encounter with scp-1000 also known as
Bigfoot in Seattle during the mid-1800s
Lord Blackwood seeking to explore the
so-called new world of North America
embarked with an assistant and an
indigenous American Guide to the Pacific
Northwest in search of the legendary
Sasquatch the trio was headed for Mount
Rainier then known as Tahoma during the
journey Lord Blackwood found a young fox
caught in a trap that had been set by a
local tribe he took sympathy on the
animal and freed it allowing it to run
away to safety that night he and his
assistant met up with the rest of his
guide's tribe and they settled down for
the evening however things took a
disastrous turn when the camp was raided
by a rival tribe almost everyone was
slaughtered in the process and Lord
Blackwood and his two companions were
hauled Away by the enemy tribe for a
Sinister purpose sacrifice to a violent
local deity as it turns out the creature
that this tribe worshiped was the very
same one Lord Blackwood and the others
were trying to find a particularly large
and aggressive Sasquatch each night a
different sacrifice was made to the
Sasquatch the victim would be placed
near a force clearing while the tribe
played a primal song and the Sasquatch
would emerge from the trees to devour
its prey the first night it ate the
assistant the next night it ate the
guide and then it became time for the
sacrifice of Lord Blackwood himself as
Blackwood was presented for sacrifice he
accepted his fate but instead of the
Sasquatch a legion of woodland animals
emerged from the trees foxes Elks
raccoons and more themselves painted
with tribal symbols the animals seemed
to be on Lord blackwood's side and
attacked the tribes people who had been
holding him captive giving Blackwood the
chance to flee into the forest during
the chaos later these same animals would
find Blackwood again and present him
with things his captors had stolen
an elder FOX also gave him a letter
proclaiming him a knight of their people
now he was allowed safe passage back to
a nearby settlement at which point he
wrote to his financiers back in England
explaining the situation and asking for
more money to perform further
Expeditions into the Tahoma region the
whole incident had only increased his
thirst for adventure and exploration
whether this tale is actually true or
just a bizarre Colonial fantasy from the
pathological Mind of a telepathic sea
slug we may never know but it doesn't
make it any less interesting to this day
Lord Blackwood continues to be a
perplexing but fascinating anomaly he
may not be the most dangerous and he may
not be the most useful either but
there's no denying that perhaps we'd all
like to sit next to his tank for a
couple hours one day and hear him spin a
good yarn over a warm cup of tea a
Panacea is defined as a remedy for all
difficulties and diseases it is a
medicine Poe Ocean or other item that
can pull a patient back from the brink
of death and save someone from even the
worst of circumstances a cure-all it's a
wonderful idea one that would save
countless lives put a stop to Untold
needless suffering and improve The Human
Experience on a permanent global scale
unfortunately anyone claiming to have
the solution to all problems is likely
just trying to sell you something unless
of course that person works at the SCP
Foundation then they just might be
telling you the truth because they just
might be telling you about
scp-500
scp-500 also known as the Panacea is
completely unassuming in appearance all
it consists of is a single plastic pill
bottle filled with exactly 47 red pills
this is All That Remains of the world's
only known miracle cure when the pills
were first discovered by the foundation
they were used in a variety of EXP
governments in order to determine the
limits if any of their Curative Powers
they tested the pills on everything from
diseases like cancer to physical
injuries like a broken femur in each and
every case one pill taken orally cured
the test subject of all symptoms within
a matter of hours after determining that
scp-500 could treat natural ailments the
foundation scientists decided to apply
it to more unnatural ills two pills were
authorized for use with
scp-008 to be administered to class D
Personnel who had been exposed to it at
the time of this experiment's approval
there were 57 pills in the can
scp-008 is a complex prion or a
misfolded protein with the ability to
change the shape of correctly formed
variants of the same protein prions are
considered to be the cause of mad cow
disease among many other debilitating
neurodegenerative diseases
scp-008 is no exception to the
Devastation it takes what is terrifying
about other prion diseases the loss of
cognition the onset of dementia the
certain death and cranks it up to 11. 20
hours after the onset of symptoms the
infected person will slip into a coma
but that is not the end of their
suffering the nervous system is damaged
and the cells have begun to necrotize
but the infected person is still able to
move they shamble around on two legs
they crawl they grab and they fight they
seek out stimuli that indicate the
presence of a living uninfected human
and they will attempt to devour it the
only way to stop an infected individual
is to completely destroy their brain
essentially it is a Zombie Plague
understandably the foundation has a
vested interest in curing and containing
scp-008 and so the promise of the
Panacea was an enticing one for the
purposes of the experiment a member of
the Class D Personnel was ran randomly
selected and exposed to scp-008 within
three hours he began to exhibit symptoms
running a fever of 105 degrees and
coughing and vomiting uncontrollably
wanting to see if it would be possible
to use scp-500 as a cure even in the
latest stages of the disease the
scientists conducting the experiment
allowed the symptoms to progress with
the test subject eventually slipping
into a coma once comatose the cell
degeneration quickened until he began to
move again his dull unfocused eyes
roamed around the room and he lurched
towards a member of the research staff
biting down on her arm of course she was
clad in Hazmat gear in order to prevent
infection but the class D no longer had
the cognitive capacity to understand
that the researcher seized the
opportunity to wrench his Jaws open and
stuff one of the scp-500 pills down his
throat once the pill had been swallowed
she vacated the room and the test
subject was quarantined after two hours
the research team returned to
investigate the results of their test
what they found was something amazing
sitting in the cell was a completely
Lucid healthy if a bit confused man with
no signs of the disease that had
previously ravaged his body the Panacea
was able to cure scp-008 even at its
most advanced stages so they knew that
scp-500 could cure a prion disease like
008 but what else could it cure what was
the extent of its marvelous medical
power if any could it cure an ailment
with virtually no basis in modern
medical understanding next one pill was
approved and allocated for testing with
scp-409
scp-409 is a rock formation resembling a
large quartz crystal it is kept in a
sealed Granite case and no one is
permitted to touch it with any substance
other than granite unless during active
experimentation anyone who comes into
physical contact with scp-409 suffers A
peculiar and nightmarish faint they will
immediately begin to crystallize their
body effectively turning into rock the
crystallization occurs at a rate of
roughly one inch per minute and will
continue until the victim's entire body
inside and out has solidified it is an
incredibly painful process and thought
to be completely irreversible subject
409-d5 was chosen at random from a group
of Class D personnel as the guinea pig
for the next scp-500 experiment he was
exposed to a cp409 touching it with his
index finger this small touch was more
than enough to seal his fate upon
contact the finger immediately began to
crystallize spreading up his hand his
wrist and his arm over the course of
several minutes as he screamed in agony
it was difficult to administer scp-500
with all this screaming but a researcher
was able to close his mouth long enough
for the pill to be swallowed within a
few hours the foundation Asian
researchers watched as the
crystallization process slowed and then
stopped after nine days in a foundation
Hospital Ward the crystallization
process had completely reversed and the
man was returned to normal he still
reported phantom pain in the formerly
crystallized parts of his body but even
that cleared up after several more days
after the incredible success of the
scp-008 and scp-409 trials the
foundation was desperate to synthesize
their own version of scp-500 a multitude
of experiments were performed in an
attempt to isolate the active ingredient
in the pills but every time they found
what appeared to be the miracle aspect
of the anomalous pills they found that
they were unable to synthesize it and
have it produced the same results as the
real thing extensive drug trials were
conducted leaving a trail of injured and
dead d-class Personnel in their wake
with the traditional pharmacological
route eliminated the foundation decided
to expose some of the pills to a variety
of other SCP ease in an attempt to
somehow recreate or amplify their
effects most of the results were
lackluster or completely uneventful
however some did yield notable results
one pill was taken from scp-500 and
placed inside of scp-914 which is a
large Clockwork device with a multitude
of settings ranging from very fine to
rough that is capable of transforming
matter in various ways the pill was run
through scp-914 on the fine setting and
the Machine produced a small silver
locket which would later be classified
as
scp-427
scp-427 retains some of the healing
properties of its original form able to
regenerate damaged cells and Purge
infection from the body when it is
opened and exposed to a living subject
during testing it was able to cure the
common cold in a matter of minutes
however unlike scp-500 the locket
produced a notable negative side effects
prolonged exposure to scp-427's healing
properties increased cell regeneration
and the Optimus station of bodily
systems Beyond a healthy threshold
exposure for more than an hour turned
the test subjects into shapeless masses
of tissue nicknamed flesh beasts these
flesh beasts are highly aggressive and
will attack anything in sight unless
they are put down
scp-427 was intended to be a potential
replacement for scp-5000 once the
limited number of pills ran out but the
potential risks of its use have led to
it being shelved indefinitely with all
attempts to create a different yet
equally effective version of scp-500
ending in Failure the foundation instead
tried to find a way to duplicate it in
one case an experiment was conducted
with the intent to produce more of the
Panacea pills not using chemistry and
compounding but instead opting for a
much more unusual method after a request
was submitted and approved five pills
from the bottle were selected to be
exposed to
scp-038
scp-038 is a highly unique plant
resembling a common apple tree however
it can grow far more than just apples
the tree can clone any object that
touches its bark producing the Clone on
its branches where an ordinary tree
would bear fruit the five allocated
pills were touched to the fabric of the
tree and sure enough clones of the red
capsules begin to sprout within seconds
but while the tree was able to clone
pills that looked identical to scp-500
their effectiveness was sorely lacking
compared to the originals clone pills
were only approximately 30 effective in
curing the infections they were used to
treat as opposed to the 100
Effectiveness with the real deal the
Clone pills were set aside for treatment
of less severe infections and all the
originals were returned to their storage
container well almost all of them as the
experiment was wrapping up a d-class
participating in the experiment managed
to pocket one of the five pills
allocated for the test the pill's
absence was not unnoticed until the
following day at which point it had
already been ingested by the
when interrogated the man admitted that
he had stolen the pill in order to cure
a particularly nasty hangover after his
usual method of pickle juice a bacon
sandwich and aspirin had failed the
employee was promptly terminated and
security around scp-500 was tightened
significantly following this incident no
Personnel below level 3 were permitted
to handle scp-500 in any capacity when
it was initially brought into the
foundation there were approximately 57
pills and scp-500's container and
currently only 47 remain due to the
limited amount of pills and inability
thus far to duplicate them in an
equivalently effective form
experimentation with scp-500 has been
drastically limited most requests for
experimentation or allocation of pills
are promptly denied these requests have
included a Dr Gibbons who asked that two
pills be given to him for his personal
Med kit as well as a proposed experiment
involving scp-253 a group of cells which
Bears some strong resemblances to cancer
several concerned Personnel at the
foundation have worried that scp-500 may
have another anomalous effect that it
may cause obsessive fixation in those
who spend a great deal of time with it
leading them to experiment with it again
and again unable to let it go until they
crack an unsolvable code this has been
immediately dismissed as trivial and
unfounded by the scp-500 research team
surely their obsessive work with the
pills is their own choice but perhaps
the concerned parties have a point after
all there are a few things more
compelling than a miracle cure and there
is arguably no greater scientific
discovery that could be made no higher
Mountain than one could climb and there
is nothing more maddening than having
that life-saving pill in your grasp and
watch the number dwindle down one pill
at a time like grains of sand slipping
between your fingers with only 47 pills
left and no way to recreate them on the
horizon perhaps the Panacea is both a
blessing and a curse a tantalizing
Glimpse said what Humanity could have
but will never truly achieve but hey
maybe they'll Crack the Code if they
just try one more experiment and why not
try there'll still be 46 left and then
45 and then well let's just hope they
figure it out before they truly are all
gone
merry Christmas happy holidays and
freaky Festivus to you all from your
good friends at SCP explained deck the
halls with boughs of
scp-407-induced plant life because today
we're gonna hit you with the kind of
Christmas cheer you just can contain
hang your stockings pour a tall glass of
eggnog and slip on your most hideous
Yuletide sweater because this is a
ketter kind of Christmas we've discussed
Christmas anomalies both in depth and in
passing on this channel before like like
scp-466 the positively terrifying mule
man whose ritual Christmas time slaying
strike fear into the hearts of families
everywhere or scp-784 Christmas cheer a
community where it's Christmas every day
and anyone who refuses to show the
proper spirit is dragged off and given a
forcible re-education in the reason for
the season there's even the pitiful
scp-1933 a fat sweaty and perpetually
drunk middle-aged man in a Santa suit
who has Irish cream for blood reminds me
of my Uncle Frank but today we're
dealing with something really special a
Christmas variety show hosted by
everyone's favorite anomalous Foundation
researcher
scp-963 sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry we mean Dr bright Dr bright
is getting ready to receive guests for
his Christmas party like no other and
the good news is is we're all invited
there's going to be stories songs comedy
and more cameos than you could shake a
yule log at so get comfortable it's
gonna be a fun one but first a quick
message from this episode's sponsors the
fine folks at the shark punching Center
the first and last line of defense
between us and those dark-eyed
sub-aquatic menaces and of course the
latest kiggle-tastic product from our
good pals at the doctor wondertainment
toy company a perfect stocking filler
for the Christmas season that's right
we're talking about spider party just
Add Water for 80 000 legs worth of
arachno funbia warning parental
supervision required your definition of
arachnophonbia May differ from that use
by Dr wondertainment avoid use of this
product if you're sensitive to spider
venom not for use in households with
pencil which are situated on reclaimed
toxic wastels and or Indian burial
grounds doctoral entertainment is not
responsible for any cases of spyderitis
spyderosis or spidermania caused by use
of this product not to be used for
gambling purposes without the express
written consent abuctor entertainment oh
and of course an additional thank you to
our friends at the Mana charitable
foundation for their generous Grant more
on that one later while Dr Brian
prepared for guests
scp-1845 a collection of freakishly
intelligent animals including a raccoon
a crow a baby pig a chicken and a fox by
the name of King Eugenio prepared a
dress rehearsal for a nativity scene
conflict erupted when the chicken kept
flubbing her lines and the other cast
members found it strange that King
Eugenio insisted on playing the baby
Jesus himself by all accounts he was
kind of a nightmare to work with thanks
to his massive ego the situation
worsened when
scp-329-j a floating yield sign that
believes it's a ghost turned up claiming
to be the Ghost of Christmas Past and
started bothering King Eugenio if you
think this is weird you're going to have
real trouble with the rest of this so we
recommend sitting back putting your feet
up and just rolling with it cause it's
only gonna get stranger from here anyway
back to the living room with Dr Jack
Bright who was singing a special SCP
Foundation parody of the Christmas carol
God Rest Ye Merry Gentlemen when the
first set of guests arrive it was Dr
Charles Ogden gears a famously humorless
Foundation senior researcher dressed in
his own adorably gaudy Christmas attire
but he wasn't alone he'd brought special
musical guests Captain and tennial the
classic 1970s Duo responsible for hits
such as Love Will Keep Us Together and
Muskrat Love they'd actually attended
gigs like this before but thanks to the
beauty of Class A amnestics it was all
new to them Let's ignore the murky
ethical implications of that and keep on
trucking next this Christmas
Extravaganza careened into another
anomalous skit this one featuring
scp-1192 a little boy named Timmy who
was somehow transformed into a bird and
counts rockula a badass heavy metal
Aficionado summoned by
scp-1987-js anomalously sick chord
progression Timmy was naturally a little
upset about being trapped as a bird and
thus he was unable to spend Christmas
with with his family count rocula being
the Lord of ultimate rockness refused to
let the poor bird boy suffer in order to
cheer him up he grabbed his guitar and
launched into a spirited rock and roll
Christmas Carol with Much racier lyrics
than you'd probably expect from a
wholesome Christmas tune the count was
left feeling a little nervous afterwards
when Timmy started asking him what a
camel toe was the sooner we get away
from this little disaster of a segment
the better back to Dr Bright's living
room once more the good anomalous doctor
had just finished telling a hilarious
anecdote to Dr gears and 1970s music
Powerhouse Captain Antonio when Dr gears
took the opportunity to break some bad
news a certain very Rowdy former party
guest had found out about this year's
Meetup and he would likely be joining
any minute now much too Bright's dismay
as if On Cue the door burst open and
there stood
scp-076-2 also known as able The
Immortal swordsman wearing an ugly
Christmas sweater and a Santa hat
yelling did somebody say party
Dr bright was mortified at last year's
party Abel had gotten tanked on hard
eggnog and embarrassed them all in front
of country music legend Willie Nelson
with his Antics specifically he'd stolen
a local sleigh and used it to run over
Bright's grandmother hilarious however
Abel insisted that this time around he'd
be well behaved only time would tell if
that prediction held any water he began
to sing a personalized parody of Away in
a Manger in a grading falsetto voice as
an act of penance let's get away from
those goofballs again and hop over to
another Ace comedic Duo Lord Blackwood
and Wellington G Wonder Horse Blackwood
also known as
scp-1867 is a telepathic sea slug who
believes he was once a galavanting
British noble and Explorer and
Wellington also known as scp-1156 is a
talking horse with a thick Cockney
accent and a Dapper Woolen scarf and Top
Hat this pair of talking creatures
wished the audience a very merry
Christmas before engaging in
conversation however this didn't get
very far as Lord Blackwood couldn't
understand Wellington's thick Cockney
accent when Lord Blackwood got too
frustrated to go on he called Wellington
a horse's ass everybody laughs roll on
snare drums curtains now then back to Dr
Bright's increasingly chaotic Christmas
house party Abel was already getting a
little sloshed and telling wild jokes
when another guest appeared at the door
when Dr bright answered he saw Dr writes
a female fellow researcher standing
there in a full body trench coat she
expressed a desire to meet Dr bright
under the mistletoe to which he replied
writes I I didn't put up any mistletoe
this year but writes obviously in the
Christmas spirit with a smile on her
face and with no concern for the lack of
mistletoe at the party disrobe from her
trench coat donned in her hand knitted
wool Christmas two-piece she began to
dance towards Dr Brightwall singing a
parody of the Saucy Christmas hit Santa
uh baby okay um let's cut to another
word from one of our sponsors the
wonderful Folks at the Mana charitable
Foundation the world's leading anomalous
charity group in this sponsorship break
man a charitable Foundation
representative Sally Struthers placed a
small mechanical Contraption on the
table and said this is the Christmas
miracle maker thanks to state-of-the-art
terraforming technology this durable and
easy to use device once activated will
induce rapid and aggressive climate
change in order to transform its
surrounding environment into a perfect
snowy Winter's day just in time for a
White Christmas the seed banks and
genetic samples contained within it will
ensure that Majestic Evergreens just
right for decorating and reindeer
perfect for pulling a one-horse open
sleigh will replace all the local flora
and fauna and it can even whip up a
Christmas dinner with all the trimmings
for those souls in need every one of
your donations puts us one step closer
to our goal of manufacturing and
airdropping 15 000 of these units across
Africa in time for Christmas Eve so
please call in your pledge or write a
check today and let them know it's
Christmas time again thank you Sally
let's get back to Dr Bright's party now
things are looking a little more safe
for work if only slightly at least
decorated Russian mobile task force
operative agent strelnikov had joined
the party and was naturally beginning to
make multiple jokes about how much he
hates chechins much to the discomfort of
everyone else in attendance the other
party guest tried to make him discuss
literally anything else but he refused
repeatedly circling back to telling
stories about chechens he only broke
from his diatribe to give a rendition of
the formerly popular Trololo meme song
which he insisted was a traditional
Russian song of homecoming back to King
Eugenio the fox who'd been going through
a parallel Christmas Carol narrative
this whole time during Dr Bright's story
The Talking yield sign was his Spirit of
Christmas Past and while we sadly missed
his Spirit of Christmas present as we
join him before his own gravestone we
can see that his spear Spirit of
Christmas Yet to Come was
SCP-173 the sculpture as the sculpture
pointed towards King eugenio's Grave and
judgmental silence Eugenio came to terms
with what a jerk he'd been when he was
freed from this horrible fantasy he
realized that he needed to change his
ways and thankfully there was still time
back to Dr Bright's Christmas party
which was in full swing however Captain
Antonio who had been in charge of
cooking the Christmas goose had made a
terrible mistake they were told to run
it through scp-914 on the fine setting
which would create a wonderful Goose
roast but instead they ran it through
the very fine mode turning it into a
collection of live goslings however in
their greatest hour of need a hero Rose
Dr clef appeared at the door dressed as
Santa Claus with enough delicious clam
chowder for everyone and as the party
guests enjoyed their chowder even more
guests arrived King Eugenio Wellington
SCP-173 Lord Blackwood the ghostly yield
sign count rocula Timmy the bird and
even Sally Struthers while the rest of
the anomalous animals formed a perfect
nativity scene while count rakula
performed a rock and roll rendition of
Come All Ye Faithful Dr bright was
content that everyone here had learned
the true meaning of Christmas after all
even King Eugenio had learned a lot
about being more kind and compassionate
to his fellow beasts with the help of
Lord Blackwood he obtained
scp-662 the butler's handbell and used
it to summon Mr Deeds along with a
delicious fully cooked Christmas goose
with all the trimmings while Dr Wrights
flirted with Abel and the other party
guests prepared to enjoy their chowder
and Goose Dr bright wished everyone a
happy Christmas with Timmy adding and 3
14 three bless us everyone we hope this
little exploration into how the
foundation celebrates Christmas has
helped your heart grow three sizes this
day and not in the way of wood if you
ate a meal off of scp-807 stay tuned for
a ketter kind of Hanukkah and a ketter
kind of Kwanzaa coming soon researcher
Alice was having a very long day working
at the SCP Foundation can sound like a
pretty exciting job to an outsider the
problem is when you deal with something
exciting every day of your life it
starts to become as mundane as brushing
your teeth or pouring your morning bowl
of breakfast cereal over time everything
loses its magic she had the unenviable
job of double checking the anomalies and
seawing of site 77 glorified box ticking
she trudged from containment chamber to
containment chamber everything seeming
to be in order tick tick tick it was all
Euclid and safe class anomalies anyway
hardly major containment risks but when
she reached the chamber for
scp-2805 the security cameras normally
used to observe the anomaly were on the
Frets she'd need to go inside great when
the chamber doors opened she felt an
immediate chill her breath came out as
an icy fog in the distance she saw a jar
sitting on a Podium the glass so frosted
over she couldn't quite make out what
was inside no sign of a Containment
Breach she took the box next to scp-2805
on her clipboard and moved on several
hours later researcher Alice was at home
finally able to relax since she started
working at the foundation dealing with
deadly creatures and cursed artifacts on
a daily basis she'd longed for the
simple Comforts of childhood in her
downtime that's why she decided to spend
her evening with a warm mug of hot
chocolate a bowl of ice cream and her
favorite animated Disney movie Mulan she
had just pressed play when she got a
phone call from an unknown number with a
frustrated groan she picked up the phone
and answered the voice on the other hand
was a little Gravelly but it sounded
kind his diction was old-fashioned a man
from a bygone era why hello there young
lady I hope this isn't a bad time he
said the names Walt Walt Disney perhaps
you've seen some of my Motion Pictures I
was wondering if I could trouble you for
some help with a project of mine this
might have been some stupid prank call
maybe Dr bright or Dr clef was bored and
decided they wanted to mess with her the
fact that she was watching a Disney
movie at the time was pure coincidence
after all they own half the movies out
there these days but that's when Walt
carried on talking to her you she my
dear I'm a little short on time at the
moment I realize I am perhaps don't have
the longevity that I used to I won't get
into the illness right now but what I do
know is that I might not be able to put
my final idea into practice is and I
believe that you and your organization
may be able to help your arm uh what
what is it called SCP Foundation and
that changed everything researcher Alice
immediately knew that this wasn't a
prank call a member of foundation staff
would never discuss Foundation matters
even as a joke over an unsecured line
and a civilian would have no reason to
even know about the foundation was she
actually on the phone with the Walt
Disney it seemed odd and a little more
than unlikely on account of him being
dead for over 50 years if only
researcher Alice had checked her
clipboard a little closer then maybe she
would have realized that she was already
under the anomalous effects of
scp-2805 also humorously known as Disney
on Ice here's a fun question for you
what's your favorite Disney movie
probably not what you expected to hear
from your friends at SCP explained but
seriously we want to know tell us down
in the comments maybe you're a classical
purist and you consider Snow White
Cinderella or Sleeping Beauty to be the
best maybe you're a fan of the Disney
Renaissance and it's the little mermaid
Beauty and the Beast or The Lion King
that are the true masterpieces or
perhaps you're a fan of their more
modern outings like Tangled Frozen and
Moana or even their Acquisitions like
Marvel movies or the Star Wars series
personally I'm partial to Tron legacy we
could go on but honestly we'd be here
all day the Walt Disney Company started
by Walter Elias Disney and his brother
Roy back in 1923 has become one of the
most powerful and influential
entertainment companies in existence
their corporate machine is so huge and
sprawling it Rivals the size and scope
of the SCP Foundation itself and its
influence the way we look at everything
from mice to Pirates to Norse Legends to
Space Battles some give the United
States President the title leader of the
Free World but anyone in that position
would happily drop everything to take a
phone call from the CEO of the Walt
Disney Company even today the company
may be a global superpower these days
but none of it would have been possible
without Walt himself born in 1901 Walt
started his legendary company at the
tender age of 22. who would have known
that he would leave such an indelible
mark on human culture during his 65
years of life but he's not just an
entrepreneur animator writer voice actor
and film producer he's also decades
after his death an anomaly currently in
the capable hands of the SCP Foundation
while his cryogenically frozen severed
head is anyway and simply looking at
that severed head is what puts such an
anomalous damper on researcher Alice's
nice quiet evening confused don't worry
let's start this demented Disney fairy
tale at the beginning by which we mean
the end of Walt Disney's life Walt
Disney accomplished more in his life
than many of us would be able to claim
in several lifetimes he'd built one of
the most enduring entertainment
companies of all time won countless
Awards and made millions of dollars from
his Creations including the Disneyland
theme parks the man had essentially made
his own name synonymous with magic
childhood Whimsy and dreams coming true
however rather than focusing on the past
Walt wanted to keep his eyes on the
future his Grand Vision went far beyond
movies and theme parks he wanted to
shape the way Humanity lived for
centuries to come and the name of this
Vision Epcot or the experimental
prototype community of tomorrow while
you may know Epcot has a mere portion of
the theme park in the Florida Walt
Disney Resort Walt himself actually
intended it to be so much more as the
full name suggests he dreamed of
creating a functional community of
tomorrow with over 20 000 residents in
his own words Epcot will take its cue
from the new ideas and new technologies
that are now emerging from the creative
centers of American industry it will be
a community of tomorrow that will never
be completed but will always be
introducing and testing and
demonstrating new materials and new
systems and Epcot will always be a
showcase to the world of the Ingenuity
and Imagination of American free
enterprise it was certainly a utopian
idea though fans of Bioshock might find
their eye twitching with flashbacks to
Andrew Ryan's disastrous Rapture however
Disney's problem didn't lie in his plans
but in himself despite his achievements
and Larger than Life Legacy he was still
a mortal man when Walt tragically
contracted lung cancer he finally became
aware of the fact that he may not live
to see his beautiful Epcot dream
completed and despite having all the
money in Fame a man could possibly ask
for he was beginning to realize that his
fortune couldn't buy him a second of
extra time or could it this question
would soon be answered when
representatives of a mysterious company
known as the owner Roy Collective
approached Walt the strange thing though
was that the entities that comprise this
elusive group of interests contacted
Walt in his dreams you see the owneroy
collective are a group of entities known
as the honoroy or dreamers who exist
only in the dream space but sometimes
interact with our world through
anomalous sometimes semi-organic
Creations they sell as products in that
sense they were the original imagineers
their Creations include scp-2028 a few
hundred snow globes that allow the user
to remove and store their nightmares and
negative feelings within and
scp-1498 which are creatures made from
old-fashioned rotary phones trailing a
huge number of wires coiled and arranged
into sheep-like bodies by calling the
phone on the creature's face a person
can order a custom Dreamscape from the
honor Roy naturally as creatures who
depend on dreams to survive the owner
Roy were big fans of Walt Disney a man
who built a career of encouraging
children to dream their little hearts
out in exchange for his contributions to
the Dreamscape they'd cut him a deal
they'd give him a special kind of oneroy
technology that would allow his
Consciousness to continue to exist and
interact with the Physical Realm after
his death all they need to keep was his
head it was certainly a strange deal but
Walt was thinking of his children his
grandchildren and their children and
grandchildren if he died now then his
Tomorrowland dreams would die with him
he'd simply be known for some charming
animated films and a couple of amusing
theme parks not for truly changing the
future it seemed that the deal with the
honor Roy Collective was too good to
resist the deal was struck and
Arrangements were made to preserve
Disney's head in Consciousness after his
death ten days after his 65th birthday
on December 15 1966 Walt Disney passed
away but that was only the beginning of
his new anomalous life while the public
mourned Disney's head was secretly
removed and preserved in a jar with
anomalous cryonics technology the device
is also fixed to a pair of rotary phones
a trademark of the honoroy and an
inscription that reads Siberian
solutions from the oneroy collective the
anomalous effect was simple anyone who
looked directly at Disney's Frozen head
would receive a phone call in the next
24 hours this phone call would be from
Walt Disney himself presumably
inhabiting the owneroy Dreamscape now
with this handy trick he'd be able to
maintain his Communications with the
rest of the Walt Disney Company in
secret and see the creation of his
precious Epcot project to its completion
but unfortunately that's not actually
how it happened following Walt's death
his brother Roy took over all Walt
Disney Company operations while the
profitability of the company didn't
suffer under Roy's control Walt's final
dream did Epcot mutated from the
sustainable functional community of the
future that Walt desired into a mere
theme park the Disney fied World's Fair
that all Orlando Disney park visitors of
today would recognize as it turned out
most people in the Disney Company
weren't actually eager to take orders
from the former CEO's severed head as a
result he became kind of a dark company
secret hidden away within the Disney
parks after a number of reports of calls
from Walt Disney after the
entrepreneur's death the foundation
finally started to take notice they
conducted a thorough investigation of
the various Disney bases of operation
and eventually found Disney's Frozen
head soon redesignated
scp-2805 in a secret compartment in the
legendary Pirates of the Caribbean ride
he was relocated to site-77 soon after
for further testing where his anomalous
abilities were later discovered sadly
for
scp-2805 while his calls to Foundation
staff have all consisted of attempts in
enlisting the foundation's help in
making his Epcot dreams a reality nobody
has yet taken him up on the offer since
his containment the foundation's main
priority has just been suppressing
conspiracy theories about the existence
of Walt Disney's cryogenically frozen
head a task which they undertake with
collaboration from the Disney Company in
order to muddy the waters in 1981 they
began Productions of Walt Disney's world
on Ice later known as Disney on Ice a
traveling ice skating show since then
they also released the incredibly
successful film Frozen and its sequel to
corrupt any searches for key phrases
like Disney's Frozen or Walt ice it's
been an incredibly effective smoke
screen as you can probably expect from
the SCP Foundation and sadly for Walt
and fans of a mid-century perspective on
the future it's likely that Walt
Disney's dreams will stay within his
disembodied head so if you're hoping to
prove the existence of This truly wild
anomaly or somehow get in contact with
Walton help him bring Epcot to its
intended Glory you should probably just
let it go what makes someone a hero
there is never just one answer to the
that question some will tell you that
it's selflessness putting other people
before oneself that makes someone heroic
others believe that heroism takes
someone with a clear sense of morality
the ability to tell right from wrong
with absolute certainty perhaps a hero
should also be a symbol a paragon of
Hope and virtue for all of society to
look up to and aspire to be and then
there are those who would argue that a
person can't possibly be a hero unless
they possess one key trait whether that
comes as a result of a freak accident
gamma radiation exposure or mutated
genes being blessed with extraordinary
powers and the will to use them for good
might just be what elevates a moral
selfless and symbolic hero into
something more a super hero it is rare
that the SCP Foundation encounters an
anomalous creature or entity that it
considers to be harmless there are of
course exceptions but perhaps even more
of a rarity is an SCP that seeks to go
out of its way and use its anomalous
abilities to do good so many of the
creatures and entities kept contained by
the foundation have malicious intent
like damage regenerating reptiles with
contempt for Humanity and Eldritch
beings with desires to take over this
Dimension but then there is scp-2800 or
as he prefers to call himself cactus man
the spiked Menace partially human and
part succulent plant
scp-2800 is one of a rare breed of scps
one that aims to help people rather than
killing them enslaving them or wiping
reality as we know it from existence and
as you might be surprised to learn that
this superhero known as cactus man began
life as one Daniel McIntyre an average
guy from Scotland little is known about
Daniel's origin story all superheroes
have one of course but as far as
Foundation researchers are aware cactus
man wasn't jettisoned in a hard from his
dying Homeworld to the safety of Earth
it is also safe to assume he didn't get
pricked by a radioactive Cactus or have
his DNA infused with a plant during a
genetic experiment he was first
encountered by the SCP Foundation whilst
they were trying to contain another SCP
a reality warping object that had
somehow breached containment what
Foundation staff tracking the object
witnessed was cactus man attempting to
assault the escaped SCP to little
success following this encounter
Foundation Personnel convinced cactus
man to allow them to contain him he
complied was designated as scp-2800 and
researchers began investigating the
nature of this strange would-be
superhero according to Daniel one day
his powers just happened with little
understanding as to how why or what had
caused this transformation when asked
about how he acquired his powers during
an interview with SCP Foundation
researcher Dr love Daniel said taviana
stuck I don't know I woke up one day and
boom Cactus Powers thought I might as
well use them for good right I always
grew up reading a lot of comic books
always loved the X-Men as a little kid
so I thought I was one of them I thought
I was the luckiest guy in the world
ending up with superpowers doesn't every
kid wish they could be a superhero
analysis by Foundation research staff
revealed that Daniel's DNA had somehow
merged with a genome of a Carnegie
gigantia plant or a saguaro cactus this
plant is usually what most people
picture if they were to imagine a
typical Cactus and is known to be native
to the Sonoran Desert as well as the
Mexican state of Sonora how one became
part of Daniel McIntyre's genetic makeup
is baffling it seems highly unlikely
that a saguaro cactus would grow
naturally in Scotland given that the
country has a far damper and colder
climate than the scorching hot deserts
that saguaros normally thrive in
regardless of exactly how Daniel became
fused with a cactus his body shares a
number of the same physical properties
of the plant pointed by spikes protrude
from his skin which can grow to just
over an inch in length it seems that
scp-2800 can either remove these spikes
manually with little pain or will
eventually shed them naturally over time
allowing more to regrow in their place
as well as outwardly looking like an
anthropomorphic Cactus
scp-2800 also shares various biological
traits with this cacti counterparts
Daniel's body no longer functions in the
same way as that of an ordinary human
being in a number of different ways
firstly he is able to perform
photosynthesis deriving the necessary
nutrients he requires from direct
sunlight this negates the need for him
to consume any food and prevents him
from feeling hunger or the fatigue this
can often bring additionally his altered
biology allows Cactus men to store more
water than would normally be possible
for the average human and he requires
less of it too
scp-2800 is able to keep himself
hydrated with a third of the required
fluids for an average person Daniel can
also adapt to more arid environments
with drier climates and above average
levels of heat having little impact on
his abilities speaking of abilities
scp-2800 is not just a man with a
physical and biological traits of a
saguaro cactus he also has superpowers
that seem well let's say inspired by a
cactus while perhaps not as flashy as
being faster than a speeding bullet more
powerful than a locomotive or able to
LEAP tall buildings in a single bound
cactus man does possess his own unique
set of superhuman abilities derived like
his other traits from his part Saguaro
DNA
scp-2800 has the power to empathetically
communicate with other plant life unlike
telepathy and the ability to communicate
solely through thoughts empaths like
Cactus men are able to influence or
interpret the emotions or moods of
others so similar but a little more
subtle in its Effectiveness cactus man
might have superhuman Powers altered DNA
and a mysterious origin but another part
of a hero's journey is the struggle an
scp-2800 is no exception to this either
despite its desire to do good he Harbors
a lot of unrest under that prickly
exterior after extensive psychological
examination by the researchers at the
SCP Foundation Daniel was diagnosed with
two distinct mental disorders the first
of these is dysmithia or chronic
depression with the other being a
conditioned colloquially known as hero
syndrome hero syndrome as its name
suggests is often characterized by an
Unstoppable pathological urge to help
people usually ignoring any risks to
oneself in the pursuit of assisting even
total strangers some with this disorder
will even attempt to manufacture
dangerous scenarios in order to act like
the hero and earn themselves recognition
and praise for reacting heroically to
the danger they secretly caused like for
example committing our sins so they can
save people from a burning building
scp-2800 has never attempted anything
like this so far but cactus man does
Express an extreme willingness to help
people and try to intervene in any
situation that he thinks he can assist
with the problem is
scp-2800 is hardly an experienced crime
fighter and this has put him on the
receiving end of his fair share of
injuries during his first outing as
cactus man the spiked Menace Daniel
encountered a group engaging in the sale
of illicit substances and attempted to
apprehend them while he was able to deal
a cactus spine-filled blow to one of
their faces the group quickly
overpowered Cactus men and beat him
until local law enforcement arrived to
save him determined to prove himself a
hero though Daniel returned to
patrolling the streets soon after but
met with the same results even weak
Petty criminals seem like they were too
much for cactus man to handle while his
hero syndrome compels scp-2800 to want
to do good and set a good example it is
also directly linked to his other
condition his dysmithion by attempt
tempting and failing to be heroic cactus
man becomes chronically depressed yet
still has the urges brought on by his
hero syndrome to put himself In Harm's
Way for the sake of others and when he
is unable to provide help Daniel falls
back into depression it's a very
difficult cycle in the hopes of
counteracting some of Daniel's struggles
the SCP Foundation have gifted him a
pair of potted cacti these occupy
scp-2800 sell with him both oxygenating
his room as well as boosting his morale
although he has remarked that the cacti
don't say much to him Beyond I'm thirsty
and I am a cactus Daniel has
affectionately named his potted plants
they're now known as cactillad and spiky
girl his Sidekicks in the never-ending
battle against evil during interviews
with Foundation researcher Dr love
Daniel admitted that he was a victim of
bullying throughout much of his
childhood from a young age he often
found himself in physical altercations
with bullies that singled him out and
picked on him at school cactus men said
that his experiences encouraged him to
give back and that despite having
suffered at the hands of bullies it made
scp-2800 determined to help others in
need in his own words Daniel didn't want
what happened to him to happen to
anybody else and it is highly likely
that these experiences from his youth
are at least part of the cause of his
hero syndrome however another incident
may also be linked to scp-2800's
condition despite not often prevailing
against Petty criminals there is cctv's
surveillance footage of cactus men from
before his containment by the SCP
Foundation the footage in question was
taken at a Subway close to where Daniel
patrolled and looked for criminals to
apprehend in the surveillance tape a
woman and her child can be seen waiting
at the subway station near a support
pillar from behind the pillar an
assailant in a mask appeared wielding
what look to be a knife the woman
cowering and trying to protect her child
was made to open her purse as the
attacker threatened her with his knife
but then cactus man appeared behind the
man he walked up to him and punched him
in his lower back and chest a number of
scp-2800 sharp cacti spines end up
lodged in the man's skin causing him to
drop the knife in pain during the
ensuing scuffle
scp-2800 was able to tie the man up thus
saving the woman and her child the woman
then thanked cactus man shaking his hand
and embracing him her child also
expressed gratitude with scp-2800
kneeling down to face them and appearing
to get emotional at receiving
recognition after signing an autograph
for the child cactus man then
disappeared from the scene before police
arrived cacti have the tenacity to grow
and Barren desert environments surviving
on very little water it is for that
reason that to some these plans have
come to symbolize strength resilience
and endurance this one encounter
captured in this surveillance footage
May well have been one of the few times
cactus man ever succeeded at being
heroic but perhaps it is all he needed
to encourage him to keep trying to seek
out wrongdoings time and time again even
if it led to him being injured maybe
knowing that just once he had succeeded
in Saving a woman and her child was
enough to convince him that he would one
day be able to do so again and maybe
that is what makes someone a true hero
the power to endure the year was 1975.
it was a warm June evening in South
Carolina and 14 year old Jason White was
ready to prove his medal like a lot of
boys his age it mattered a great deal to
him that his peers saw him as strong
tough and most importantly of all Brave
that's why he was camped out alone just
outside of the junkyard as the sky went
dark above him he'd heard rumors about
the things that went on inside the
junkyard scary things unnatural things
but Jason wasn't about to let those
stories scare him he knew for a fact
that the junkyard had been abandoned for
months if not longer nobody was in there
he'd be fine or at least that's what he
kept telling himself with the moon high
up in the sky Jason crept into the
junkyard using a flashlight's beam to
light his way behind the towers of
busted down cars and scrap metal he
heard a distant but loud grinding noise
was it coming from one of the warehouses
no that's impossible he thought just his
mind playing tricks on him but curiosity
compelled him to get closer Jason
approached the warehouse and saw that
the big iron door was still a jar his
heart was in his throat as he peered
into the building and saw the impossible
it was a man no a machine cobbled
together from pipes wires and aluminum
it was using a power saw to cut apart
metal on a workbench but it wasn't just
one robot there was movement all around
it jerking and twitching in the shadows
as his flashlight being passed over them
Jason saw the moving living bodies of a
menagerie of metal creatures he screamed
in shock and the robotic denizens of the
warehouse all turned and looked at him
Jason had never felt more afraid in his
life until the humanoid robots still
carrying the power saw turn and began
walking towards him it was waving his
free hand around wildly in what Jason
perceived as some kind of threat letting
out another animal Screech Jason turned
and ran all the way out of the junkyard
until the sounds of clanking metal faded
out behind him Jason was scarred for
life and in that moment he vowed never
to return to his local junkyard ever
again and this was a wise choice because
not long after that a very different
group would be commandeering the
junkyard and as fans of this channel
will know they don't take kindly to
Intruders if you've ever been on a long
road trip through a rural part of the
United States you've most likely seen a
few quirky signs and wacky looking
businesses along the way whether it's a
diner with a dinosaur protruding out of
the front a gas station shaped like a
UFO or a particularly weird mural
businesses in the small towns lining the
freeways often have to get creative when
it comes to attracting patrons locations
like this saw their Heyday in the 1950s
and 1960s but as the cost of gasoline
skyrocketed in the 70s and technological
advances in aviation made flights more
accessible as a form of travel less and
less people were making long
cross-country drives on a regular basis
this caused an economic downturn in many
small towns and led to a large number of
quirky and unique roadside locations
being abandoned by their owners some
have been torn down or remodeled but
others remain as they were hanging on as
tourist destinations and serving as
reminders of a bygone era one such place
that you might encounter if you ever
find yourself heading down I-95 south is
Jamaica Joe's junkyard Jubilee the
colorful storefront is decorated with a
mural depicting a picturesque tropical
Lagoon while a sign reads one love in
hand-painted green and yellow letters at
first glance this might just seem like
Another Roadside Oddity but if you were
to try and check it out you'd be blocked
by a patrol of six armed guards SCP
Foundation agents of course and
depending on how much you saw you might
be administered an amnestic before being
sent on your way because Jamaica Joe's
isn't just another junkyard it's
scp-100 scp-100 came to the foundation's
attention on November 9
1976. after tracking a series of rumors
about a mysterious abandoned scrapyard
where the machines ran on their own and
strange metal figures could be seen
patrolling the grounds when the
foundation arrived at the site they
installed wooden privacy screens around
the fence of the junkyard replaced the
storefront windows with one-way glass
and redirected the highway through a
nearby town to keep civilian traffic
from getting too close Jamaican Joe's
junkyard Jubilee is 5 000 square meters
of fenced off land located in rural
South Carolina as the name suggests it's
a junkyard made up of two warehouses a
storefront a small residential building
and a storage space containing roughly
1500 vehicles of varying makes and
models some of which have been
compressed into cubes there is also a
variety of other metal scrap on the site
altogether valued to be worth about five
thousand dollars pocket change to an
organization like the SCP Foundation
just like many other cases where the
anomaly cannot be relocated to a
pre-established foundation containment
site for research the SCP Foundation
instead brought the research to the
anomaly the larger of the two warehouses
on site is now the de facto Research
Center for all matters involving scp-100
as well as a temporary residence for
on-site staff it is important to note
that there's nothing anomalous about the
location in itself but within the area
of the junkyard are a variety of
euclid-class anomalous entities the
property was at one point owned by a man
by the name of Joseph Duvall presumably
the titular Jamaican Joe however the
whereabouts of Mr Duvall are unknown
Research into local records show that
the utility bills to Mr Duvall's
personal address had stopped around
three months before the junkyard was
found upon the first sweep of the
location the foundation found no
evidence of human habitation save for
one note taped to the door of the
storefront reading out to lunch please
see assistant JJ the first anomaly that
was cataloged on the site was scp-100-1
a humanoid automaton made of scrap metal
mainly copper wires and tin cans
scp-100-1 has a limited degree of
sapience and although it has no means of
verbal or written communication it does
speak through the use of rudimentary
sign language it seems uninterested in
conversation though unless the topic has
to do with the sale of scrap metal the
information the foundation has been able
to learn from scp-100-1 has been limited
but the fact it appears to be mostly
work and very little play is incredibly
clear what it lacks in conversational
skills it makes up for in craftsmanship
scp-100-1 has been shown to be very
Adept at using an arc welder drill power
saw and other Machinery found around the
junkyard through its metalworking skills
it is able to create more beings like
itself from the scrap that surrounds it
when given the chance
scp-100-1 usually creates automatons
that resemble one of four animal species
Flamingo crocodile turtle or iguana
however it's also able to create metal
copies of other creatures from Bugs to
domestic pet breeds like cats and dogs
while the foundation usually destroys
the new constructs created by scp-100-1
it has been allowed to keep two in order
to keep it Placid and preserve a cordial
working relationship with the foundation
operatives on site these two metal
creatures which both resemble large
metal insects have been designated as
cp100-2-a and
scp-100-2-b though it seems scp-100-1
has named them Ray Monet and Beatrice
respectively based on the fact that
those names are welded into the backs of
the creatures Raymond a and Beatrice
fulfill the role of perimeter guards as
well as companions to scp-100-1
scp-100-1 and its pets are peaceful in
nature and in fact if they ever breach
the perimeter of the junkyard they lose
all autonomy seeming to shut down until
they are brought back within the
perimeter as such containment breaches
are nearly all to come from Outsiders
trying to infiltrate the building rather
than any of the anomalies escaping
scp-100-1's main function seems to be
running the junkyard in the absence of
the mysterious Jamaican Joe Duvall it
spends most of its days sorting scrap
metal building new constructs and
Performing maintenance tasks around the
yard and the robot seems to follow a
very strict ritualistic schedule from 8
AM to 3pm scp-100-1 enters the
storefront area of the junkyard when a
customer enters the shop
scp-100-1 will take its position behind
the front desk and begin bargaining with
them using hand gestures to convey
meaning
scp-100-1 possesses the ability to
perform the basic mental arithmetic
required to keep track of sales despite
seemingly being unable to read when
scp-100-1 has been observed making sales
to customers the foundation has found
that the robot can be very underhanded
and unfair when it comes to running its
business like a kind of metallic Mr
Krabs frequently it has been seen
intentionally selecting low quality
scrap or using scales that it knows are
faulty in order to scam customers it
also sells the animal automatons that it
creates knowing full well that they will
stop working soon as they're taken out
of the junkyard in cases where customers
have rightfully come back to demand
refunds
scp-100-1 invariably responds by
gesturing to a sign on the wall which
reads no refunds mom written in a
phonetic Jamaican accent after clocking
out for the day at 3 pm
scp-100-1 spends an hour maintaining and
socializing with Raymond a and Beatrice
it's two insect-like pets it'll also
communicate with them through hand
gestures and will engage them in games
of fetch or hide and seek in the
junkyard from 4 pm until 8 PM
scp-100-1 spends its time ticking stock
and cleaning all the tools and Machinery
on the premises it also takes time to
clean both the interiors and exteriors
of the various buildings on the site
then at 8 pm it appears to wind down for
the day with some leisure activities
including making more constructs playing
some more with its pets and taking
strolls around the perimeter of the site
this leisure time lasts until midnight
when scp-100-1 will retire to the
residential part of the junkyard the
robot doesn't need to sleep but it does
seem to rest sitting motionless at a
desk from Midnight until 8 A.M when it
resumes the schedule again from the
beginning this was all that was observed
at scp-100 for decades following its
Discovery
scp-100-1 was seemingly content with its
life and with the tasks that came with
running the junkyard however on June 3rd
2005
scp-100-1 did something it had never
done before as mentioned
scp-100-1 had only been seen using its
skills to create autonomous animals from
scrap metal but on June 3rd it chose to
create something else another humanoid
the automaton was only 10 centimeters
tall but scp-100-1 took great care in
crafting it much more so than any of its
Creations it gave the small figure
distinct facial features and made the
whole thing from high quality stainless
steel when scp-100-1 was finished with
its creation it welded the letters JJ
onto the back and took it into the
storefront during its 8 AM to 3pm shift
that day
scp-100-1 sat at the desk with JJ on the
desk next to itself and the two seemed
to carry on a conversation through
signing and gestures as was policy with
all of
scp-100-1's constructs excluding Raymond
a and Beatrice JJ was confiscated which
scp-100-1 took very badly following JJ's
removal
scp-100-1 returned to the residential
building and stayed there remaining a
nerd for a total of 10 days it is unsure
what really happened to the original
Jamaican Joe or what his precise
relationship was with scp-100-1 given
the difficulty in communicating with
scp-100-1 it is possible that we'll
never know for sure but from what little
were able to glean from the enigmatic
out to lunch please see assistant JJ
note he left behind it's very possible
that before he left Jamaican Joe may
have created the best assistant to
junkyard owner could possibly ask for
congratulations SCP explained fans
you've just scored yourselves front row
seats to the freak Show hey don't be so
nervous I know clowns don't necessarily
have the best rep these days thank you
very much John Wayne Gacy and Stephen
King but I guarantee you I'm not like
the other clowns at home and follow
circus of the disquieting I'm as human
as you are well okay that's potentially
debatable depending on how stingy you
are with your definitions and what
exactly counts but we'll get into that
later see I'm what they call an
anomalous humanoid known to the Egghead
to work for Miss SCP Foundation as
scp-2094 object class Euclid whatever
the heck that means my friends call me
Bonnie on account of the fact that's my
government name but if you're a fan of
the circus you probably know me better
by my stage name motor mouth pretty
fitting nickname ain't it I try to make
Barney the bottomless happen in the
early days of my career but it wasn't
catchy enough to stick then one day my
buddy Quincy threatened to Bob a swarm
of bees on my face if I didn't shut my
mouth then that's been my stage name
ever since now that would properly
introduce you probably wondering what
cool tricks I have up my sleeve to get
me that Nifty SCP designation well it's
not because of my heightened manual
dexterity my juggling skills my
accordion praying prowess or even my
nearly perfect impression of Jane Fonda
as Barbarella so if you guessed any of
those you're way off base see I'm the
subject of a quote unquote spatial
anomaly accessible through my mouth and
my throat in plain English I've got a
second stomach anything I swallow
disappears into a pocket Dimension made
of anomalously elastic intestinal tissue
where it's stored until I need it again
if there's a limit to how much I can
store in there I haven't found it yet
the amount of stuff in there has no
effect on my overall weight or my
ability to move once it's in there it's
just kind of gone until I want it back
on top of that my lower jaw can be
stretched up to six feet at two meters
for those of you we're those who use the
metric system in any direction so in the
addition to being a juggler and a clown
I also made the killing as a geek at
Hermann Fuller circus I don't mean geek
as in all the sign James T Kirk Funko
Pop that's still in mint condition I
mean the sense of somebody who gets paid
the weird junk as a form of performance
although I have been accused by some of
being both now you're probably thinking
Mota mouth my power my good body there's
so many couriers you could have gone
into with that very specific set of
skills garbage disposal one-man moving
man service left luggage abandoned at
Grand Central Station sky's the limit
man well sure but I love the circus
they're the only family I've ever got in
this world that came to them when I was
just a wildlife Punk kid of eight years
old and they took me in like I was their
own flesh and blood yeah believe it or
not I wasn't actually born into the
circus life a lot of circus and
Performing Arts folks are born into the
industry born in a costume trunk as they
say but unfortunately that's not me I
was born in New York City on April 10
1976. my dad had took off long before I
showed up leaving me in the care of my
dear old mom my special abilities
manifested early and my mom recognized
them right away you know how little kids
are always putting things in the mouths
right it's killed when it's a block or
an action figure but less so when it's
the entire coffee table yeah my mom was
fully aware of what I could do and she
hated my guts for it not only had a baby
daddy flown The Coop but the kid she was
racing was a freak of nature who she
could barely stand to look at and trust
me the feelings of resentment were
totally Mutual one of my favorite
pastimes as a youngster was to go out
and find as many small animals as I
could get my little hands on then go
back inside where Mom was laid out on
the Pilot chair sleeping off one of her
special grown-up headaches she got from
Downing a bottle and a half of a special
grown-up juice I made like I was gonna
innocently ask her a question smiling
one of those adorable little
eight-year-old smiles and instead of
saying anything I just buff up a couple
dozen rats onto her lap despite how much
I hated living at home it never occurred
to me that I could leave I was a pretty
wide-eyed kid mom kept me isolated from
the Wilder world I guess out of fear
that I need somebody but one night as I
was going to bed I met Manny who's Manny
come on if you know anything about the
circus of The Squire thing then you know
manly don't you guys already have a
video on that that many short for the
man with the upside down face he was
Hermann Fuller's right hand in charge of
a lot of the backstage stuff including
shall we say Talent acquisition who
knows how he figured out where I was or
that I could even do what I do but just
like magic he showed up in my window
should I have been worried that a man
with an upside down face was at my
window probably but I guess I was just
happy to see someone who was more of a
freak than me Manny offered me a place
in a real family where I wouldn't be
cooped up he said that freaks belonged
out in the world sharing their talents
making people laugh and cry and puke all
over the place I didn't hesitate I took
him up on his offer mommy dearest was so
deep in the drink that she didn't even
notice I left and that was that from
that day forward I was a member of
Herman Fuller's family I never looked
back not even once now it may also
surprise you to know that I wasn't
always the picture of confidence I am
today my first job with the circus was
as the human clown car as a kid they
didn't have a lot of stage presence and
I didn't talk much so the natural thing
to do was to send me out to the ring and
let the clown through come marching out
of my mouth to the surprise in the light
of the audience I learned juggling from
a guy named Scythe he was a human pin
cushion but like most of us at Hermann
Fuller his abilities were Way Beyond
what you'd see at any common or God In
Circus Scythe was incredible at what he
did you could stick a shiv in every
square inch of this guy and he'd never
bet an eye total jerk though and awful
with kids so how he got the job of
training me in the ways of the juggler
is totally Beyond me if I so much as
talked out a turn he'd beat me in the
head with a juggling pin not hard just
enough to hurt I know that sounds bad
but at least it toughened me up I think
Scythe was jealous of me in hindsight I
was a natural and I think he saw me as
you know some kind of threat Scythe
eventually died in the Firestone come
wrong they held a funeral for him but I
was busy that day clowning I learned
from a guy called scruffy mcgrubbins
good old scruffy he had all the grace
and countenance of a chain-smoking
grizzly bear and he was worth more than
all the grandmothers I never had he
never talked to me like I was stupid the
way most people talk to kids scruffy
took me seriously and he invited unto me
all the knowledge he'd picked up in his
years in the circus trade he was a very
wise man this clowns go he never means
words never messed around with small
talk he just jumped straight into a
conversation and expected you to catch
up I never knew what happened to the guy
I already quit the clown Biz and settled
down in a nice apartment in Kent I hope
he's having a good day wherever he is so
I did the juggling thing for a while
passing around balls and bins and other
junk and catching in my mouth sometimes
I'd put a plant in the audience call
them up and swallow them whole as a part
of the ACT eventually I started working
on a double act with another freak by
the name of Theo see Theo could flip
himself inside out but he was also
pretty skilled acrobat so he'd do a high
dive jump over the audience blow his
insides outside the name himself down my
gullet he was a pretty great act if I do
say so myself they will not even dated
for a while what can I say a fun guys
just as fun to swallow as gals after he
and I broke it off I decided I needed to
change up my ACT that's when it hit me
motor mouth picture this he is me an
assistant on either side ready to pull
my mouth open then a Chrysler comes
barreling into a big top hits a ramp
drives right into my mouth into my
second stomach it was a dangerous act
the magic show but not immune to being
run over but it was the best act I ever
came up with I could tell you some
stories about my time with the circus oh
there was this one time my tapeworm
started talking to me at the time I was
involved in overthrowing the room and
follow himself and installing icky as a
new ring Master at the time I hooked up
with one of the non-human Capital C
clowns so this is a family-friendly
channel so maybe not that one no that's
not what you want to hear though is it
you'd rather hear about how I got myself
captured and locked up by the Miss SCP
Foundation
all right why not I've already spilled
the rest of my backstory so Manny you
remember Manny from earlier right you
saved a lot of kids like me and when he
did he usually put me in charge of
teaching them how to perform but there
was this one girl he brought in who
broke down crying in the middle of one
of our juggling lessons she said she
wanted to go home that's when I knew
that Mania graduated from saving
runaways and abused kids like me to
abducting kids with powers of course I
confronted him about it I told him Point
Blank That's not how we do things
anymore Herman hadn't been around for
years at this point we were better than
that give me some garbage about him
doing what he had to do to keep the
circus alive
do you believe that even with everything
we were doing he still thought the
circus was on the verge of collapse so I
took the girl home stole them I got and
snuck her onto the Kaleidoscope that's
the machine we used to move all the
parts of the circus from place to place
the kid was back with her pants before
dinner but when I returned to the circus
Manny was Furious in hindsight I think
it nearly killed him to do it but he
said he had to make an example of me so
he threw me in a box locked in with
chains and painted the words for SC on
the top I was left out in the field in
camerano Japan like a wrapped present
for Miss SCP and that's how I ended up
in containment truth be told I slept in
prisons more comfortable than this place
the Beds Are Hard the food is gross and
the little red light on the security
camera keeps me up at night not ideal
conditions for a circus Superstar of my
caliber but as my old pal gory Lantern
skull used to say it's the performer
that makes the stage now go check out
threat in The Game
scp-1733 season opener an scp-426 I am a
toast for more of the downright weirdest
anomalies out there and uh while you're
here come get me out